the following is a presentation of the
st louis chess club
[Music]
welcome everybody we are here in the
2022 summer chess classic and it's time
for the final round to bring in the
action i'm grand master alejandro
ramirez here with my good friend
grandmaster christian carrillo alejandro
always a pleasure to be here in studio b
maybe the final tournament the broadcast
it from here from studio b to call the
action of the best chess players that we
have here in st louis tell us a bit
about these two tournaments that we have
on our hands alejandro coming to an end
it's kind of sad to see tournaments come
to an end but we need to crown victors
we had two very strong round robins for
you guys we actually made it all the way
to the end uh which is surprising for
some players but happy that we did so we
did have a couple of players that had to
withdraw due to illness but we made it
to the end and we are ready to crown
champions today two very strong
tournaments one about average of 26.50
the other one around 25.50 really really
strong events these events allow them to
catapult players to the elite really
yeah and the experience that some of
these players are getting is just
incredible oh absolutely and let's take
a look at the standings as we enter
round number nine the championship round
we're going to start with the a group yu
yang yi is leading with authority uh
this tournament right now one point
ahead of his closest competitor that is
abhimanyu mishra the young abimanu
mishra the youngest competitor in the
event also the lowest weighted player in
the event with four points in second
position tied for third we have jonas
bier grigorio parin nicolas thioderu and
benjamin gledura on three and a half
points tied for seven we have elias
mirin sam savion and aram jacobian with
three points a piece and unfortunately
ray robson did test positive for kovid
and had withdrawal after round four and
how about the big group alejandro where
do we stand in the b group things are a
little tighter there at the top we don't
have a yu yang yi who has taken a full
point lead over his rivals guillermo
vazquez actually currently has six
points and that is due to the fact that
he is playing brandon jacobson in the
last round brandon again also fell ill
not necessarily of course we don't know
what he had but he had to withdraw from
this tournament and guillermo with that
gets six points but out of nine which
means that both uh jj ali morandi and
misha and tipoff are within striking
distance and interestingly they play
each other we'll talk about that in just
a second uh camille dragoon is currently
on fourth place and in fifth position we
have young zhou uh john burke
christopher yu and luckless so far in
this tournament have been tigran
harutonian and niko who are rounding
down the bottom of the table with three
and two and a half points now let's talk
about the tournament format alejandro we
do have a two tournaments closed events
10 players at the beginning of the event
unfortunately after those withdrawals we
are only left with two nine player round
robbies 90 minutes for the first 40
moves 30 minutes for the rest of the
game and a 30-second increment starting
from move one and uh tell us a bit about
social media alejandro how can the
audience reach us well we're actively
monitoring our chats on youtube and on
twitch and of course we are also uh
reachable in twitter at
summerchest classic and remember that we
have this going on for every 75 that we
get in donations and bits and subs we
are going to be able to provide a full
semester of chess programming for a
talented youngster here at the saint
louis chess club uh coaching imparted by
some of the top grad masters here of the
area so 75 really goes a long way to
support these tournaments to support the
youth of saint louis and it really does
uh provide the resources that the chess
club needs for all the amazing projects
that is such an important mission uh
that the st louis chess club is getting
engaged into and
let's talk about the pairings alejandro
and we're going to start with a group a
what do we have here as we are entering
this important championship round yeah
the championship round is set with two
huge matches uh of course benjamin
gladuar against gregory opparen and aram
hakobian against elias miranda certainly
important uh the tournament is going to
be decided in the last two boards it's
going to be ambi manu mishra against
nicolas theodora be mind you is the only
person uh player in this tournament that
is actually within striking distance of
you young yi so there's a crucial one
for abimenya who's had an excellent
tournament so far a plus one score that
could honestly have been a little higher
i think uh based on a couple of his
games and nicolas teodoro who bounces
back yesterday beautifully with a win
against sam savion from his loss in
round two against jonas pierre so far
also having a great tournament because
these two are having such an event that
they have a key matchup on the last
round and they are the two lowest rated
players in the tournament absolutely
what an incredible feature absolutely
and of course very important as well the
17 year old from denmark jonas beer
having also a great tournament on plus
one is now playing against
is he actually on plus one i thought he
lost to uh opera he did lose to abarin
actually yesterday in round number eight
uh what you see there as a draw it's
actually a
loss and he is playing you young he who
won yesterday's uh game against aram
hakobian what a beautiful attacking
masterpiece that was we left it off
right before he delivered the final
sequence to get the full point and right
now in fact as we look at this position
it seems to me that it is black who is
playing for a victory yeah in this game
and let's not forget with a draw young
he wins this is a tournament right but
he might actually win this one what do
we think about the position it's holding
on for a threat if holding on at all for
white uh the problems are quite clear
black has all the activity and more
importantly this light squares around
white's king just a complete disaster
right it looks like a swiss cheese over
there uh especially the fact that black
has a light scored bishop and white has
a dark squared bishop emphasizes how
weak all of these squares are and it
it's almost a miracle that i can't find
at a checkmark checkmate a direct
killing blow in this position something
that wins something uh the knight on d2
unfortunately is covering b1 which is
pretty much the only thing keeping white
from immediate resignation because queen
bee one would otherwise just pretty much
finish the game uh or bishop to couldn't
be one some combination of that but uh i
don't see it right now that being said i
could i could play it slow right
i'm hanging on by a thread yeah you can
also play a bishop to g4 for example
yeah but that will be met by the only
move in the position queen to f1
you cannot take on g4 because that would
just be losing but uh let's take a look
at the pairings for the b group
alejandro as we enter the ninth round we
see either that kamil dragoon actually
already won
against the grand hari haru the union
zoo zhanchao is still playing against
nikolcheka brandon jacobson of course we
know uh he withdrew from the event and
uh that gave guillermo vasquez a full
point in the last round christopher u
against john burke and misha antipov
versus jj ali marandi and this is indeed
the key matchup of round number nine
because as we uh can see misha antipov
started off timidly uh with five draws
in the first five rounds but after that
he started turning it up and in sixth
and eighth round he got the full point
right now he's on plus two trailing
still the leader uh one of the leaders
as we entered this round jj ali marandi
and uh jj with plus three he has to
defend this very very difficult position
and also
you have a story for us about jj
alejandro tell us a bit about that
well uh jj of course has had a great
tournament he is one of the most
improved players i would say in in
collegiate circuits uh he managed to go
from i am all the way to 25.50 starting
to win these events so amazing
resurgence here by jj he's in a lot of
trouble today but he's also in time
pressure not actually on the clock here
but uh his flight today is i think it's
at 5 00 pm okay so if you somehow get
some tie breaks i have heard a rumor an
unconfirmed rumor
that he will either have to decide
between a tiebreak and making his flight
to turkey
so
that's an international flight uh
there's not many of those and that might
be an issue in did now we have this uh
knight to c5 came on the board after
sacrificing a pawn try to bait the
dark square bishop on h4 on the other
side of the board and leave unattended
the queen side for white species what do
we think does white have enough
compensation and let me just turn off
i did have uh well yeah the engine on
unfortunately i i can definitely tell
you whether
white has enough compensation or not
um but let's try to understand the
position of course
96 is like a huge threat so he goes king
h7 right king h7 came on the board and
now
i understand the bishop h4 is kind of
misplaced you don't really have a lot of
ideas to get it back in to play but
where's where's the blow where is the
final blow well what if i start with the
simple move knight e6 i hit your rook uh
the knight is also hitting the pawn on
c7 it might force you to go rook c8
exactly because rook to d7 doesn't work
right because you have knight f8 which
is very annoying for black knight to f8
indeed and perhaps uh
we can take a look at uh these games as
well
but yeah knight to e6 actually is on the
board yeah was played forces black to
make a decision as you were mentioning
alejandro look to d6 unfortunately
bishop to a three counts yeah bishop a3
also you could probably just pluck that
pawn on c7 uh i don't see anything wrong
with it
so in both scenarios that actually rook
a3 bishop a3 traps i broke i see your
point
um
yeah it's just an uncomfortable position
for black because you have to move the
rook off of the d file
you might as well put it on c8 i think
because
i don't think it's doing anything useful
in any other one of the files i mean
rook b8
looks more threatening than it is i
think because after the move bishop a3 i
still think that you have to defend this
pawn on b7 on c7 sorry
uh so you might as well put it on cd
immediately i think i'm not really sure
but
black isn't black is in a position where
he can't move right right that's knight
b6 doesn't move
and i don't c6 doesn't have any real
potential moves i mean look you're going
to get the bishop to g5 but what after
and rook to b8 by the way was played
so the idea is that knight c4 will
will simplify the position right for
example if i take on c7 it's a threat
it's a yeah first of all you can
probably take on a4 actually you cannot
yeah yeah yeah let's check because check
on b2 yeah i don't have time to take on
c6 so
uh yeah rook to b8 definitely a cunning
move now
bishop a3 looks very logical to me just
to move the bishop out of the way
makes a lot of sense right yeah you
never know when knight f8 is also a
resource
yeah it just looks like
actually it's a big resource later on
and i do think that that's when i see a
movie in just a second it's hard not to
play bishop a3 here yeah bishop a3
played
um
i think this one we expected kind of
easily let's take a look at the time
four minutes right now and 19 seconds
for antipov and 48 minutes
a very fast player but
it's only seven moves for white to make
and it's not the most complicated
position right black has very few
threats uh if you give me a free move i
can play rook d1 actually if you give me
a free move as white i'll just play
knight f896
and that's two
i'll go rook d1 knight f56 that's two
more that's that that makes sense
no i like that uh strategy of course so
for example just to
show the audience what we mean by that
if you go king to g7 yeah keep
connection with the pawn on g6 now i can
just simply play the move knight to e6
you cannot go either on f7 or g8 because
that will allow me to give a discovery
check knight xg5 with devastating
consequences so you have to keep going
came to h7 and allow me to now
change the position look to d1 and then
then i'll do it again again and
this mechanism allows white to reach
move 40 vertically
oh yeah he won't be in any time pressure
bishop to a3 right now jj is taking a
pause phil j is in trouble despite the
extra pawn
yeah these bishops are controlling the
knights quite well and this bishop on h4
spawn h4 is just uh he did munch yeah
but but i think he's gonna get his hand
stuck in the cookie jar here yeah yeah
yeah this one is um
it's not looking great for a jj and
remember this is a crucial game right if
a wins he's actually catching guillermo
vazquez and we would have a playoff for
the winner of group b at 5 p.m that's 5
p.m central time so we will probably
take a short break and then we will come
back
now um
quite interesting position we do think
that white is definitely in pole
position to take this one ah
i hate to interrupt you but we have to
jump to the br game
to the beer game yeah absolutely right
because there's like unfortunately we
cannot oh we cannot yeah
well we can see the position we can see
the position
of a beer we cannot analyze it oh we
cannot analyze it that's that's that's
good enough because i don't think we
need we need we can do this one mentally
yes because this one is uh close to over
i think
uh if you look at take a look
okay if you think with the bishop queen
f3 king e1 bishop anywhere like d3 has
just made
right i think that's pretty clear yes uh
bishop takes d2 queen f3 king g1
probably again bishop somewhere and
queen d1 is made
okay yeah at least picks up the bishop
on d2
i think i'm right um
which means that you have to take on
e4
with the sorry on e2 with the king right
now
but i think that after 94 your position
just collapses like queen b2 is
unstoppable maybe queen b5 also wins
i feel that king takes e2 knight e4 is
it's just that yeah yeah knight x2
bishop d2 obviously uh doesn't feel like
uh it's working king takes e2 seems to
be the forced move in the position
at the same time i have to say i'm
looking at it all the pieces
uh in black in black's camp swarming
around the white king it just doesn't
feel like he's going to be able to hold
on no
and you have to take on e2 right away uh
what is the time situation 15 minutes
against 31 so no no real time pressure
for either player who's just uh i think
you're just cruising cruising at this
point i think young has really shown why
he has the strongest player in this
tournament uh
he helped so far yeah by far he he was
in trouble in two games he was in
trouble against glendora and he was in
trouble against theodoru and he still
managed to make a relatively comfortable
draw considering the positions that he
was in yeah and in every other game he
was either putting pressure or just
destroyed his opponent uh and this is
one of them i mean he just destroyed
beer from the beginning
better knowledge of the opening and then
position another knowledge of the middle
game or the middle game as well yeah
uh better knowledge and better handling
and i have to say that's one thing about
beer he's an extremely strong player
the only department in which he lacks is
experience yeah well very young right
it's very very young players very young
very promising player and i'm sure we
will see a lot
of him in the upcoming years right now
he's just fresh on the circuit yeah
absolutely
knight to c4 um
and this is exactly what we said is
probably going to happen queen to b2
will be coming
base a2 i can just simply move on to
such a devastating threat and you start
you start munching on the pawns and
this bishop on e3 never gets better is
the yeah and i think beer is already
understanding that he knows he knows
yeah he knows it he's trying to find the
last few moves nevertheless he doesn't
feel like there's going to be many of
them yeah once you pick up the pawn on
a2 every queen and every every king and
pawn end game is just one yeah so you
can start pretty much harassing this
bishop on e3 you never really can avoid
trading it because it's so bad and it
doesn't feel like white has a great way
to come back with uh to bring back his
queen
quinto f1 will be most likely met by
either queen to b2 and just take the
pawn on a2 yeah i think that's maybe
even queen to a6 to try to be fancy
fancy right yeah but i don't think
there's any need just queen b2 take on
a2 you still haven't created a threat
yeah and queen b3 just wins the game on
the spot after that right you can't go
into king pawn and game as we said it
looks hopeless to me yeah i think it is
i think it's just that it looks hopeless
all right um and we're going to keep an
eye on this one for sure
uh what about the other game of the day
the one between nico and jojen ciao
let's take a look at that one
no no not even
what i said
i'll be mind you against nico's uh think
about the other knicker i'll be manu
versus nico and
definitely a nickel player that
has been proving why uh he is in this
tournament as well as
yeah both of these players only 25
hundreds i think if i'm not mistaken
they might be the only 2500s in at the
event unless smearing no no smears over
26. under 200. so yeah these are the the
only two players under 2600 but this is
and they're proving that and they're
proving that wrong yeah behind you we'll
finish the terminal plus one and i think
nico will finish a tournament on 50
which are great scores for both of them
uh this looks absolutely dead yeah we're
going to see rook takes c3 nothing
really to talk about here rook takes d2
this one is extremely easy
absolutely nothing happening
all right i guess we have to go back to
this uh this game between antipov and
chamilchan even though this one nothing
has happened and uh it seems like
chimchan is taking his first longer
thing of uh the round now
you mentioned the nikochaka against zhu
zhang ciao and let's take a look at that
one
what is going on in this one
let me pull that game up
who takes g6 well what's the material
count first it's actually equal
equal after you take on g6 after i take
on g6 it'll be equal
the question is what do you take with do
you think with the f i think uh it's
pretty clear right or the h bar oh no
there's nice on d4 nevermind no it
sounds clearer it's actually not so
clear yeah because i was and this game
is over we expected to draw here uh but
isn't it kind of clear if i take
on uh if i take the rook right with the
f pawn sure and i go queen e6 check i
try to become a bit more active and then
i go knight rook c8 rook c8 how do you
check made me i have one channel yeah
one check when i go to d3 but that's
more or less it yeah then
no more checks and if you don't have a
good way to defend the rook on f8 you're
getting checkmated
i don't quite see it no and that's why
and i think you have to take yeah
i think you have to take with the h pawn
yeah yeah
even if you had to even if somehow f
takes g6 survives h6 g6 is just much
more desirable right absolutely i mean
the f point is important to defend e6
absolutely and
quinto g4 came
on the board um
as you were mentioning such a
strange position you never think as you
look for the first couple of seconds at
the position that um it's equal material
but it actually is yeah it's just equal
too um strange structure the structure
is very very weird king one e2 is
actually kind of safe
yes
yes it's hard to reach this knight g3
was one move knight takes knight to f4
if the rook lands
on e8 that would actually be a big
threat so maybe why not maybe it's not a
bad move right yeah okay i'd be a little
afraid of maybe summon games like rook
c8 here uh knight f4 doesn't work so no
but now i can
either go here which is going to be met
by king d3 and that's a problem yeah
that's a problem so what if i no but i
take on a force
i take with a queen
and now i cannot take because you take
with the check and then pick up the
queen and i can resign yeah
so you have to play something like rook
takes c8 at that point i don't think you
can avoid the trade no but you know you
go king h7 and i go queen something like
d7 or c7 not c7 obviously queen d7 and i
start hitting a lot of pawns you still
have check on
[Laughter]
this two hours earlier really messed
with your uh with your chest schedule
huh it is two hours earlier that's true
all right so we actually have a team to
h7 came first
so this makes a bit more actually this
makes a lot of sense right yeah
c8 most likely is going to be met by
either knight to g3
or knight
to g3
just knight to g3 i mean i think f5 and
what could have resigned but sure
or f5 yeah that's
perhaps a better move
slightly um
yeah so rook says it's not available
king h7 is a cunning move anyway
i like it i like this move prepares
rookie uh main problem also for the
chinese player here is that he has 30
seconds left
one minute and 30 seconds i think ah
because he just played he just played
the move f4 after this move f4 yeah so
who do we who do you like more in this
position
it feels like white it feels like white
might just be winning also right if
knight is winning well knight of three
is a big of a threat so
actually actually black has to do
something
oh f4 is a brilliant movie actually f4
is uh
before the move that we should at least
have mentioned isn't your queen almost
trapped yeah that's what i'm saying
three in fact the queen is strapped yeah
knight f3 is a huge threat so i assume
knight to f6 might be almost forced yeah
but you have queen f3
going to f3 or threatening rook to h1
now
by the way some move has been played no
no f4 is the last move now you have to
drop back but it doesn't help you
that doesn't help you the queen is still
trapped yeah the queen still trap
so what you could do is go all the way
to h6
but
this doesn't work either because of
knight to f5 and once again the queen is
strapped you can take on f5 but rook
takes h5 wins wow oh wait how does he
defend then that is a very important
question right now he might have to play
f5 f5 yeah
to give himself the h3 square now the
difference is that on queen f3
i think i have queen h4 it's still kind
of miserable because you lose d5 but
correct so i'm going to try to keep your
queen
block now the only problem let's call it
a problem right is that
uh i have h3 for my queen in this
position i don't know i i'm not sure
that's going to help you
too much in the long run in the long run
because it does seem that first of all
rook g1 might be an issue
once you put a queen on h3 you don't
have any counter play i don't have any
counter play to begin with i mean i'm
just having trying to keep my queen
alive three eight
rook e8 huh right so trying to meet
knight to f3 with either queen to f4 or
knight f4 probably queen takes f4 yeah
and this actually does seem to work
at least it uh
it pins
by the way uh can i start with rookie
eight uh i wanna i just wanted to check
that tactic
instead of a five
yeah you can
no trickies right i was looking at like
knight f3 queen takes a four knight g5
something like that but i can't make it
work
so now perhaps
i'm gonna go with a king here
you could
king f3 i think i have to go f well i
have knight f6 also
yeah you have a few options no i have
more options and to be honest
this is what it's uh i predict going to
come down to
how is the end game going to look like
after we change the queens on the g file
pretty bad for uh for black or black
yeah because i have invasions
everywhere on the c file c5 c7 c6
everything is going to uh yeah beautiful
knight on d4 let's not forget that's the
yeah that's a beautiful night no
actually white might be borderline
winning
f4 we're going to leave these players i
think at this point let's take a look at
what's happening in the game between
christopher you
and
john burke and by the way uh as that
game between mishra
and theodore finished we do have a
winner
in the a group regardless of what's
going to happen in this game you young
yi clinches oh yeah the title of the
summer chess classic champion very good
for him uh we had no doubt that he was
winning the tournament the moment that
we saw his position against beer but
definitely an excellent performance here
from new young yi showing why he was 26
27 35 showing why he has a olympic gold
medal
showing
why he has superior to the remaining of
the field i mean he he was just
head and shoulders above everybody here
and actually it just finished and here
did resign right
that game uh
yeah
just uh categorical
victory for you young in this event he
started off shaky in the first round
against glendura
that was a very very difficult game for
him with the white piece but the wise
pieces he wasn't in trouble on that one
for sure but he he rectified the ship uh
winning his next two games winning
against aparri with the black pieces and
then smashing uh smearing with white
yeah so certainly a very strong showing
scores six out of eight an impressive
plus four performance
here for um that's incredible
yeah really incredible for you six out
of eight remember that we only have uh
eight rounds tournaments huge results
out of eight
six hours of wait i mean he finishes a
point and a half the game against ray
robson didn't even matter yeah
there's no no points for that one no
points for that one and that was a that
was a
game he could have won so that is
plus four plus four could have been plus
five plus four could have been plus five
incredible wow in this field
fashion
uh by the young chinese player and let's
take a look at what's happening in this
uh
game the game that could potentially
give us a victor yeah um the game
between antipov and ali marandi let's uh
not forget if alimorandi wins this game
then
he will clinch the first yep
if he draws then he's going to go into a
potential tie breaks that's right and if
antipov wins
then we're going to have a tie breaks
between himself
and vasquez that's right so everything
to play for still in this game uh knight
c4 played and
so pawns are equal pawns are now equal
as white has taken on c7 and we're five
minutes away from five moves away excuse
me from making uh time control yeah one
minute left for antipov knight is now on
c4 what do you play here as white i want
to save this bishop well there's the
option of taking on c4 king d3 and try
to make use of your c pawn and just
passing the pawn
that is one it's an option uh i'm a
little scared that
you just take on a4 right
and i guess you could take on a4 and
does your rook get trapped c4 after that
so let's uh take a quick look yeah this
is important right
because c4 threatens uh knight c3 in one
move or king c3 king b3 if you give me
two moves yeah so i would have something
i would need to have something clever
like knight e6 96 telling you that after
this you have knight to f4 metaphor
knight c5 i think both work because i
have rook takes a c4 next move yes and
he decided not to test that yeah to test
that not to give
well
one of his bishops he he is definitely
giving the other one nevertheless he
does have this move to d7 and this is
the point right i think i think you
played chuck first
you could yeah you could but the idea
being that it looks like after rook
takes d8 i'm going to recapture my piece
the problem is that rook to d7 is an
intermediary check forces the king to go
to the eighth rank
and then rook takes the 8 comes with a
check i'm going to defend my bishop on
b3 next and that's going to be winning
uh you cannot
take on a3 and follow it up with rook
takes c3 all right let's take a look at
lines knight takes a3 yes knight takes
a3 let's just whatever sure it could be
rook d7 first i don't think it makes a
difference uh here i'll play f5
okay let's give this check yeah at some
point i don't know only goes to h8
and the reason i'm playing f5 of course
is that this bishop on h4 suddenly joins
uh joining us afraid now i'm not super
happy with black's position there's a
lot of tricks that i'm worried about
knight c4 is one of them knight b5
knight d6 is another
uh yeah this is a actually a checkmating
threat yeah it's a checkmate right so
knight to c4 what do you do
how do you defend and by the way i do
think we have a move on the board not to
e6 night e6 played none of this will
happen the bishop c3
96 also makes sense to see another day
yeah knight f4 is uh is the point rookie
seven check played
keep tweeting
the players are getting closer time
control three more moves
yeah this is very
important all right so kha now in this
position
uh no real progress if i don't take this
knight on c4 or not not necessarily take
it but remove it
what if i play it by the way
where's the rook go take and
yeah we don't really have a clear option
wait a minute no no but it does this so
what if i go c4 ah now you go knight to
d4
yeah that actually yeah my idea is to go
king c3 king b you can also take on a3
you can also take on a3 and that's
actually even better
30 seconds for misha he needs to make a
decision in still complicated position
big big he goes bishop e7 what is that
threat stopping black from playing the
move f5 it also stops knight takes a3
which is a big deal so perhaps this is
the best square for his bishop it looks
odd looks a bit odd especially because
it gives this bishop on h4 a reason to
be happy it has a job
uh finally finally has a job but i i
like that the knight on c4 is no longer
threatening this bishop i mean i think
that's the main point
so what if i um no i like this move
bishop p7 i think it's a it's a good
move
the more i look at it the the more it
feels like a good move so what if i go
knight f4 here where's right where's
your give me a check
let's go with the simple decision which
is king to f3 here's a simple decision
huh
more or less looks like the natural also
because i am threatening g3
that might be a problem
what if i go something like no bishop
bishop f6 is part of the reason that is
the reason why he plays yeah
right
so the bishop h4 does have a job but he
doesn't have freedom anymore freedom
that's how it usually goes that's how
you're going that's your job you're kind
of stuck to
that job no more freedom yeah well
yeah
so what do you do
maybe maybe you ask if there's a
a thread right is there a threat
let's say i press x and i play something
like bishop g5 what is your uh
the x factor yeah the x
i could try to go g3 for example just to
kill your knight
and
a little bit your bishop um
but let's try to find wait by the way is
this a threat i was thinking about the
previous move but it didn't happen so i
assumed though then i kind of gave up uh
well he just played bishop e7 right so
he could have gotten an a7 does move
because he did attacked her
but then rook
to see no but then you take take and
you're not hanging wait so excuse me but
let's understand why 97 was i assumed
that there was something along the lines
of knight f4 but i haven't i didn't
figure it out and then they moved so
knight to f4
i and the idea is if you go here you
have knight d2 check well there's a rook
on uh d7 that's okay rook takes c7 rook
takes c3 sorry ah you guys made it
that's actually amazing that's actually
mate yeah that's very nice so yeah
because the knight is no longer on b5
yeah there's nowhere else to go
so what if i go king to d1
here at least knight e3 right here and
like the knight of what at least knight
f1 but
but what are your game yeah what are you
gaining right there is nothing gain i
okay
going back no i like bishop
in the game uh
it also challenges black to find a
useful move because knight a7 is
reactionary right you're just forcing
black to react to your move yeah here
black actually has quite a few choices
and they might not be good 97 still
seems like a threat
yeah knight a7 seems to be um
is it a threat though that is the
question because
after that knight force still works
king to f3 unfortunately i think it's
taboo in fact
because king to f3 knight to d2 rook
takes d2 we always see this rook takes
c3 coming with that's always made yeah
this knight is actually surprisingly
important on b5
so um still knight to a7 is on tap
knight a7 is something that white has in
his pockets
for the remainder of this sequence of
moves now
how can black improve the position and
this was the question that alejandro
asked how do you improve the position
and i have to say i don't see
the answer to that it's not very clear
and
as we are
analyzing
this position we do have
the winner of the a group
the champion of the summer chess classic
you young yi uh yu yani congratulations
quite an incredible performance by you
six out of eight not including the game
between you and ray robson because ray
had to withdraw how does that feel
yeah
with
mastery game of the year
in robertson yeah for a long time again
yeah i think maybe i have a
one chance one chance to win in the game
yeah but i miss
uh in the last game or in the one
between you and ray robson
is that the one that you're uh talking
about
and
maybe
or this game today's game yeah okay give
me just one second because we do have to
change platforms unfortunately we cannot
see that
[Music]
bleachers doesn't work unfortunately
we do not have
um leeches does not work and
unfortunately i cannot see it on chest
pump either so we're going to stay with
this chess 24 if that works as well
um let's take a look at this game yes it
does work
beautiful
all right tell us take us through
the big moments of this game mm-hmm yeah
you started off with knight to f6 name
so
you wanted to play uh a peaceful game
right yeah tight game you
didn't want to risk anything
today i just play solid because uh in
black piece and
maybe i have a
feel
tired because every game plays so long
time
bishop to g2 he played uh castle knight
to c3 did you expect this knight to c3
from him or were you expecting something
else
yesterday i checked her
just a lot yeah
this line yeah yeah
it took knight to c6
one of
the older main lines
which is considered to be quite okay for
black a5 e4 e4
did this move surprise you or yeah in
surprise for me because i remember i
underlined in visual d2 yeah
no e4 yeah maybe not little bit bishop
d29 before you
i think i guess i will have to consent
to uh my data being uh yeah i have to
consent to my data being stolen
that's okay knight to b4 yes yeah keep
going
oh maybe no bishop d2 queen c4
sorry
no bishop d2 yeah quincy for take
take uh
bishop a6 yeah
and now perhaps you can take this pawn
knight to c3 and bishop b2 or yeah maybe
you have t8 yeah because basically three
at the end yeah so
fb8 d8 yeah fd8 yes
i remember some some
some player
placement precision yeah
pleasant position for black oh this
expect right yeah i think this position
is equal i remember yeah
okay so he decided to play this move e4
which as you mentioned did surprise you
um
e4
knight to b4
now there's no more queen takes c4 on
the board bishop to e3
now you get to keep your pawn at least
for a few more moves
a4
queen e2 knight to d3 rook to b1
did you feel like you're taking over
already at this point we felt that that
you are how did you feel
maybe
black has slightly better for me yeah
because um
because of my space too big
space is uh you definitely have an
advantage on the queen side yeah and he
doesn't really have the bishop on g2
unfortunately yeah
leaves the king quite exposed
um
a3 you played opening up
the a and b files rotates b8 rook to b1
yeah queen to c2 yeah
i think queen c2 is mistake mistake yeah
maybe necessary
yeah it's normal bishop c6 i think fs3
f5 i don't know oh yeah
continue to attack the center try to
open up the light square bishop yeah
maybe d5 punk
yeah ef take yeah i don't know here
maybe 95 or queen f8 i don't know
perhaps try it for while try to set up a
blockade on the dark source um if you do
get to play d4
in a good version then you just simply
win so what if knight e5 know e5 i think
it can't be true
king f2 yeah
he just goes up yeah yeah this actually
looks pretty decent for white yeah okay
yeah yeah i don't know yeah
all the way up now
perhaps not knight e5 but the move that
you mentioned queen to f8 yeah this does
seem like the stronger option yeah maybe
g4 queen f6 i think the black is
no more bishop before now yeah yeah i
don't know yeah
no this makes a lot of sense and
probably
um it still gives you the advantage but
also
were you at all playing for a draw in
this game or you did not think about
that because with the draw you clinch
the tournament right you win yeah yeah
that's right i know but
um but i in
middle game i feel my position isn't
good but i just better now you want to
wait yeah once we need that right if we
if positioning is equal maybe i have a
drawing yes yeah yes yeah absolutely no
and uh already you're definitely
starting to
look quite poised to finish the game
within a victory queen to c2 knight to
e1
full control over the light squares
yeah here i think maybe
queen
kh4 maybe better try to create some
threats queen to d8 is coming and what
were you planning on doing maybe h6 h6
yeah get the king to h7
because it still looks great for you
yeah because if you right play bishop h6
i have be2 yeah
next one i've seen that's uh that's a
check i don't know right yeah
and at some point this bishop on h6 is
going to be lost right
yeah yeah i know this one is is
definitely looking good he put queen to
h3
and uh let's see how uh
you guys continued
bishop p2 and now you're just simply
taking over
gift me the pawn
and he decided to uh resign uh a
dominant victory in the last round to
cap off an incredible tournament for you
how does it feel to win here in saint
louis
yeah
i'm happy and retired because
i haven't nine runs i already play and
play every day it's a long time it's a
long game yeah you didn't get arrested
because you also had to play ray robson
just before he uh unfortunately had to
withdraw from the tournament yeah
because um
i remember i played robertson usually
play six hours it's a long time but
just i remember queens
and game i miss
is winnie
but i remember i think it was checkmate
in uh 14 moves or 15 moves yeah yeah
yeah
yes i remember
[Music]
to the end the game
is winning position but uh
i don't know how to say
i missed
camp eight yeah king a8
what would you say was the most
difficult game for you in this event
in
in first game first one yeah yeah
because
because my position is
very dangerous i feel is
lost against benjamin gladula yeah yeah
of course yeah and after that you just
gained the boost of confidence saving
that game right yes
[Music]
because
because
i remember first game if you my opponent
think of sometimes bishop e7 maybe
i just lose
congratulations once again a tremendous
performance uh by you you are the worthy
champion of the summer chess classic
congratulations okay thank you
and uh as we see there on the graphic we
do have the winner grand master yu yang
yi from china takes home a cool 6 000
what a dominant performance
games some rating points as well
10 rating points if i am not mistaken so
that's a quite a nice catch
i will say from 2710 the rating that he
currently has all the way to 27 20 and
that might take him in the top 30 in the
world if i'm not mistaken alejandra
welcome back
good to be back
what have you been uh looking at during
your uh uh your small break well uh the
most important thing i think is an
antipeople actually may move 40. he did
so okay
and he got to a position that i think we
already analyzed but he has two extra
tempi and that's actually relatively
important because we were talking about
this earlier about the strength of the
move knight a7
and this might be it this might be
finally the time so knight to f4 came on
the board as we were watching the game
um king f3 and you came to f3 bishop to
e1
no uh excuse me
back oh that's not a good sign yeah g3
bishop g5 so basically we have the same
position we had previously
but
f4 is covered in the kingston f3 so if
you go knight a7
i don't actually see um
what the point here is knight to d2
right but i can i just i can just move
my king
king e2 i think
and what if i take on c3 i think
e6 and you're probably getting made it
and i'm also just up a piece even if you
aren't yeah and there's actually no
counter chances for me
um
and if i do take on b3 you take on c8
and that's just simply winning and again
you're probably getting mated but i'm a
material don't even have to think about
it exactly
exactly
well that's uh not good news for black
if this works no that might be uh now
they said it might be a devastating blow
right now for
c7 for jj
would i just trade
92 and i go back and i think your knight
is just trapped after bishop d5 because
you could never ever ever take on
so knight to d5 you're saying that this
knight might be trapped but
i could go here and then you go king to
d3 yeah it's not so much that it's
trapped and i'm gonna win it i think you
just go bishop d8 next move you take on
a5 you can never take on d5 if i just
win the end game
i mean i just passed the pawn right okay
so let's start with this i'm going to
let you to go to d8 and then i'm going
to take on d5 yeah that's fine
so at least now at least uh the pawn is
not going
straight to promotion
but i feel like one of my pawns will be
how are we doing on on material wise it
doesn't matter i think right yeah
so somehow it became equal
um
yeah no it definitely looks good for
for white
but how do you continue you're not b5 i
think knight b5 and then just king d3
next move
let's go here let's try to take the pawn
but here i think on a5 here take on a5
no you're not on time d6
but i still have knight to c5 ah
but still yeah c4 or something i don't
know
yeah no i mean it has to be again like
completely lost it definitely looks lost
and most likely it is
i'm just um trying to figure out whether
i have any chances no it does feel like
bishop b6 followed by c5 c6 yeah bishop
bishop b6 bishop b4 it doesn't really
matter i think so big moment right now
yeah seven we think that a7 is winning
right up the game yeah
uh we haven't taken a look at a couple
of games in a while maybe we can update
them yeah which ones uh would you like
to go to christopher you again john
burke i don't know i don't even know if
we took a look at that
at that game we did not
we briefly did for like for like two
seconds and we had to go to a different
game um
so this is the christopher u with the
white pieces who unfortunately uh has
had quite a lackluster performance up to
this point not that bad right for you
christopher maybe minus two minus one or
minus eight i think it's a fifty percent
really christopher you i would be
shocked if he's at fifty percent really
am i just like completely off here
uh let me check
i should know these things
b group christopher u
[Music]
christopher yu is currently on 50 but
that does count his uh win it win quotes
against uh brandon jacobson he's a minus
one
technically on fifty percent
yeah but actually a minus one right
minus one yeah
yeah yeah yeah so he hasn't won a single
game and he lost only one no no he he
actually beat chekka um
okay sorry sorry
he's playing playing check out what am i
talking about
no he's playing burke
christopher you
beat someone who did he beat i don't
think he'd be he beat nobody yeah you're
right he also had to tune in yesterday i
don't think he didn't beat anybody this
tournament that's kind of crazy
oh yeah what a tough tournament
it's uh
it's a late morning here in st louis
very late morning very late morning
queen to a5
there we go the spy cam is back yeah
it's my favorite one
285 so how do we feel about the position
i mean why it's not the exchange right
there on d2 white is up the exchange now
the question is and it does feel like
white has enough control over the dark
squares that he's going to be able to
hide the king even on a3 even on a3 i
think it's a good move i think we know
you have to actually go three you
actually have to go to a3 but i think
that's more than fine the bishop is just
doing a great job covering that diagonal
yeah actually queen e5 just loses the
tempo i think yeah i think so
i think so
but if you don't win e5 and i do think
we have a move
well that changes the character of the
position
yes a little bit right but not by much a
lot i think because i think that if you
keep the queens maybe eventually black's
king actually becomes
so you think this is savable
i don't know if this is savable but it's
obvious that white's playing for a win
so what if i
what if i numb
take take and now let's try to invade
yeah
i think i have to defend h7 i think h7
is crucial right you could go h55
yeah probably bishop d3 i guess just no
sure and now i'm actually not going to
hurry with rook to g7 i'm going to start
with this move but here i have time to
put my bishop on g6 you are forced i
think probably forced to put my bishop
on g6 you're saying that somehow this
knight protects my invasion score on e7
this bishop protects the g file as well
as
the e8 square but what if i continue i
mean i'm not a thrilled camper
right i don't i'm not really
guaranteeing that i'm holding this but
material is pretty reduced
if you're fighting you're fighting i'll
fight right
um let's take that i'll fight this is
king c8 or something i don't want to go
king of c no no king a6 a4 gets mated
but b6 you still survive but it's not uh
it's not where you want to go because
you can never make another move forever
with the knight so king c8 but this i
mean it looks very ugly it looks it
looks like a disaster i'm going to call
it this is lost yeah the king is just
too weak i'm going to pick up
h7 a7 and a5 but it is possible that the
position is lost from the beginning
right absolutely this is not they're
going straight into that variation yeah
yeah
and also
bishop to is
bishop d3 is a better way what if i just
king b6
yeah now b4
what do you think about this i it's not
a move that i necessarily want to to
play i
wish i had one more extra move to play
the move a4 and that would finish the
game
but how do you defend you have to give
me the a7 pawn with
king to b5
you might have to play a5 but it's just
also horrible right
yeah once again if you play five but
yeah that's horrible you take i take and
if you go king a6 i go bishop c5 now but
a4 is coming and now i have the a pawn
no i mean objectively this might just be
bad for blocker i'm having a lot of
trouble defending uh
the entry oh yeah well once the row gets
to g7 i i think bishop c5 is actually
quite unnecessary yeah this rook g7 is
key once the once the row gets there
it's just too strong and black's
position is in such a situation where
all of his structure is unable to hold
back the rook they're just being picked
up by the rook one by one yep and
there's absolutely no counter play
there's no counter play the knight can't
reach anything the bishop can't reach
anything your passport on the file is
not going to go very far
so it there's no point in pushing it the
moment you push it the weaker it becomes
yeah this looks borderline lost wouldn't
be surprised if actually it is
it probably is no and and the
the presence of the opposite color
bishops also helps white right because
white can
find
the attack on the dark squares much
easier than if black had the presence of
a dark square bishop on the board
that's not the case
black is going to have to face the music
on the dark squares and the music
doesn't sound very good
let's take a look back to this game
the game of the round definitely so he
played king 2 instead of uh
knight a7 which we were thinking
okay and the knight c5 came on the board
bishop takes c5
c5
um
and black's idea after king d3 i assume
is
knight
b2 go back to c4 or something
not a lot of choices
yeah
okay
maybe i don't go king d3 is there any
other move maybe i can start with
rook d5 or something
even rook d5 here but why why be so
fancy why be so fancy 593 yeah yeah and
then you know bonds but why be so fancy
yeah but there's no point in doing that
just go k3 from the beginning
so here with d5 yeah
some other move nothing that we consider
well didn't consider that much uh no
yeah knight c7 all right that actually
probably i assume has a threat
ah this is a very smart move
you cannot move the knight
because of rook d8 d8 right and then
bishop g8 right so let's put that on the
board like for example the move knight
b6
rook d8 uh the king has to go to seven
taboo square for it
boom and you have to actually step on it
because king h7 bishop g8 forces king g7
not really
maybe i can survive this
no
that is illegal
there's no way how do i survive
i have to i have to try
nothing else but an attempt
at my disposal
where's the mate
come on let's find the mate there has to
be a checkmate here
i cannot believe
i just have to attack this cake right
that's what i need to do only once
it's funny
so for example knight to e6 rook takes
c3
and
one check
and
where is it where's the mate where's the
mate is it rook g8
i get it
but but what after no no knight f8 is a
threat
ah knight of faces
okay so i'll
bishop takes g6
where's debate
and then what i don't know what that
means i'm taking your knight
you take my knight next move i feel like
i feel we got lost in the variation
somehow
so let's say i defend this night somehow
yeah
it's not over over is it go up
i mean it's winning but
not over over it feels
it feels like we messed up
it feels like it's winning but that we
still messed up i don't know if we
messed up knight to c7 okay we're
we're taking a trauma from the beginning
knight b6 right
by the way is there any other move first
of all what is white's threat without uh
this knight moving i assumed so now some
96 must be some
unpleasant threat to deal with 96 i
still have rook c8 so it's not
such a deadly threat just yet
um
perhaps a stronger threat is to go check
and then knight e6 but you still have
the c6 square for your rook exactly
maybe it's just a seuss one
okay
all right let's go h5 h5 yeah let's make
a move let's find
some ideas
yeah it's actually very tempting because
you finally get rid of give yourself
another give yourself one square even if
it's not much it's one square
some lines it might matter
yeah no for sure knight to c7
it feels like he's so close
to winning it but i just cannot find the
breakthrough yeah but where is it right
or is the breakthrough
do you want to take on h5 let's assume
you do
might be a very wrong assumption it
might not be i mean you can the thing is
you can even slow play these things
right like knight d5 at some point you
might have to you might have to but it's
also so clear and clean right you've got
knight d5 here or something it's
improved the night yeah it's all about
the uh activity of the kings and the
difference between the kings in the
exhibition as well as the rooks the
rooks obviously the white rook is much
more active than the black rook on c5
which is a good defending piece
now the kings on the other hand my king
is tremendous while your king is in
complete shambles right now
yeah
but i still have to fight
but i mean
maybe maybe we just we're losing
patience just go knight d5 bringing the
knight closer to the king
slowly slowly i'll get there
knight d2 i can't even go to knight e7
doesn't work because you're actually
taking my bishop knight f6 bishop f6 but
it's not the it's not what i want i get
it this is probably winning it's winning
it's for sure winning but this might
actually be an easy win it might be but
i don't know i'm at this point i would
be very upset just because the king is
i'll be upset getting here really yeah
yeah
wow
you have high expectations from your
position i do
but maybe it's the best because 92
bishop eight to 94 is kind of messy
no you do have this threat
i know that's right that is a threat or
not we're still not 100 sure might be
six blades so we're actually going to go
into the questions asked
jj is asking the pertinent questions
that's that's a check
you have to go to h01 there's no choice
it seems like jj
yeah
speeding up bishop jerry after king h
also antipov is speeding up as
well somebody has seen more than their
opponent bishop to g8 king to h8
or do you just give up these checks
because there's no other alternative
that might be also the case
i mean
you mean for for black for white
not for white
yeah probably i mean you can also just
play slow something like c4
yeah knight on c7 is still under attack
so what did we look at that we looked at
this
knight to e6 96 maybe rook c8 actually
which might also be lost just by the way
correct yeah you can even take take and
you can now try to focus on this uh pawn
yeah you can push the point you can pull
you can probably just push the phone
yeah yeah i think c4 just have to be
careful about the knight d6 i don't
think so c4
i can take and bishop d5
i must be winning right
yeah i mean the knight is just totally
controlled i would love to get c5 yeah
then then we're talking but with c5
coming king d3 king c4 this has to be
over
yeah this is over
um
and
still your king is so far away
from the theater of this position yeah
that's like on another planet
all right but still he's asking the
questions
trying to put some pressure on his
opponent's time
do we cheat and turn on the engine uh we
can i think this is just over so we can
we can definitely cheat let's cheat i
think this is plus a million
not that much not that much yeah not
that much true only plus 2.4 so
there's still some technical work to get
yeah still some stuff
all right and by the way we're staying
with this game because
this is the most impactful game yeah for
the first round
as of right now we already have a winner
in group a that is you young e
um
nothing can be changed dramatically
about the standings in group a but group
b definitely has a lot of play left and
this particular game because once again
if ali marandi manages to make a draw in
this one he's going to go on to a tie
breaks yeah
if he loses then it's actually antipov
who goes into a tie breaks later on
today against vasquez now if uh by a
miracle ali marandi
does win this position with the black
pieces
that's it that's that's a miracle
but
then he would win outright
as we see the players
so
what do we have there 17 minutes and 15
seconds for antipov yes plenty of time
and uh
a big opportunity for him
out of what seemed like an innocuous
looking end game at the beginning of the
round
it didn't seem like much
yeah the beginning of the round it
didn't seem like much but the more he
kept playing the bishops eventually
became stronger and stronger until we
got to this position where the bishop on
h4 was strangely stranded yeah and the
conversion or like the switch into this
end game where the king on h8 is stuck
and a tactical target
uh i think has been very very good for
uh for the mizzou player
yeah king to h8
and now he has to
find the right configuration it's not
easy
it's not easy especially with the clock
also it does feel like you have a lot of
options
somehow
i think the worst part of his position
is that he has a lot of options yeah
yeah that's the thing just
any check right play bishop d5 if you
want yeah you could play bishop a2 with
a clear connection if you want um
any check
is available for white
if it's like every move that doesn't
blunder the knight is uh it's actually
quite interesting right knight d5
king knight e6 yeah
even like b5 any check with the bishop
yeah yeah bishop d5
and of course bishop to f7 which kind of
creates the most yeah which is very
direct but it's also kind of concrete it
does kind of uh put your pieces in a
weird so kg7 doesn't work because of
knight v6 yeah the second is very lost
so king to h7 is the right move and
as we let the players think about this
position we do have the playoffs
regulation alejandro beautiful what can
you tell us about that well it's simple
two-game rapid match of game 10 with two
second i assume that's the delay
if tai the match will be decided by an
armageddon game the typical armageddon
game that we play here at the club
which is
white has five minutes
is that a two second increment
i surely hope not but i surely hope
that's not a two second increment
in delay we have a delay in the
armageddon i see him also in the rapids
it's extremely weird this is the
weirdest
thing ever somebody wrote me this
regulations i'm tearing them up
black gets four minutes and draw odds uh
so it's not plus two it's delay of two
which are equally bad in my opinion yeah
actually plus two has to come after 60
moves so but delay might be worse i
don't know which one's worse for normal
again maybe we can can you imagine
playing around with delay can we can we
get uh the organizer on call uh and then
try to change the regulations we're
boycotting the tournament until this
gets fixed we we need the armageddon to
be five against four with uh an
increment of two seconds later on in the
game after 60 moves yeah
um
some people are thinking i think this is
one of his problems oh yeah oh yeah
he's very indecisive sometimes
yeah and look it's it's not an easy
position and there's a lot on the line
um
it is the victory of the event of the
line or a potential type ring if he does
make a draw then that's going to keep
him on i think tied for a third position
so it's a big difference for him yeah
it's a huge difference and also in price
for sec i remember that oh huge
difference a huge difference in prices
right yeah yeah absolutely absolutely so
it is a big money
decision yeah it's a huge money game for
uh for these players basically the
difference between making this an
incredibly profitable last couple of
nine days and
an okay an okay and okay last couple
nine days right yeah yeah yeah
and uh
okay we are being told by our producer
that the graphic was wrong and we will
actually
thank you updating with the correct time
controls thank god what happened with
ray uh the twitch chad wants to know
unfortunately he did get coved um
right before round four i think so as
early as round four yeah yeah he had to
withdraw from the event
unfortunate at that moment he had an uh
exact 50 percent survived against yuyani
in a marathon game
and his games did not impact the
standings because they were played
before the halftime mark of the
tournament so all the games got
announced all the games got an old all
the games that he played before getting
all the games that he plays after get an
old different from brandon jacobs
situation where because he passed a
halfway mark his rounds uh stay and all
of the games that he plays after his
withdrawal count as full point forfeits
for his opponents which include some of
the leaders of the tournament vasquez uh
right now and uh jj yesterday yeah and
tipov is actually the only the unlucky
guy in this mix uh he did play
um brandon before he got ko actually
just before he got caught well i don't
know if it's covered but the illness
that
stopped him from playing further on
um came to h8 we're still pondering and
so is on tip of the next move
we said bishop to f7 we said bishop to
d5 is an option do we have any other
options
right now
hmm
that's the thing knight we see this
thing we have so many options right i
just don't know how it changes anything
because 96 i still go rook c8
c8
somehow i feel happy when you play the
movie do you think that i have to just
go over take c3 and hope for the best
because rook ca takes takes c4 might
just be
not yet so i i guess i should start with
bishop to f7 first
just because if you
this then the bishop on g8 is uh on pre
and we've been told that uh jacobian and
smirn have drum but yeah continue with
this variation so let's give a check
first knight here six
takes takes
and just c4 yeah but here knight d6 and
but okay we go to the same position we
just talked about knight takes g5 and
it's completely winning and i i do think
it's completely completely winning so
yeah i i would not be
i mean if i'm white i'd be thrilled to
go to this position even if i see a
position where i'm up a rook this one is
like justice winning yeah no i i tend to
agree and unfortunately for
black he cannot actually save the
bishops for example if you go bishop to
c1 now i have enough time to completely
block your your knight with this move c5
now you're going to know when i go e8
and
my pawn continues
yeah nobody's stopping that one
and that's the problem your king is not
getting close to my pieces not at all
king is completely stuck
on h7 yep
um
so this is what we think
might be the best solution for this
position and by the way bishop to f7
knight to e6 as you were mentioning
maybe you're just cuffed you have to
take it
hopefully buy the bullet buy the bullet
hope for the best if you got made it you
made it and that's it yeah there's
nothing else you can do
and we haven't seen it it's not like
we've actually found a refutation to
this
no no we said rook to g8 yes director
reading a check mating threat
97 forced but maybe sufficient for now
force for now yes
you could try to give a check first and
that actually pushes me to d3 i don't
have any other options to get away i
could try to get my king to h3 but i
don't think i want to do that
um rook to d2 king to c3 and now you can
even take the pawn
but that's just going to close the show
after king to b3
so you cannot take the pawn knight to d7
finally you're forced
defending the f8 square oh sorry if you
do put the rook on yeah you take on g5
and then i take the rook
so you have to start with knight d7 yes
yeah you don't have time for rook to so
you don't have time for rooksy too you
actually do have to start with this um
but i haven't seen
exactly where where the mate is from
here i i don't see it either it's kind
of weird right
it's extremely weird uh but we did say
this check
and then yeah but in bishop g6 you have
knight f8
i don't know if you missed this at the
beginning but i think it is kind of uh
kind of annoying huh we did miss it that
that might actually win the game for
play i might actually be waiting for
black
big move
you cannot take on g6
i can take with the rook but it's not
what i want to do
no no it just feels off right
giving me too many tampies too many
tempests somehow
you know black is thinking of
coordinating here
right and you're not actually
threatening anything i'm not threatening
anything that's the problem and he's
still thinking
down to his last eight minutes oh that
is the if you're a jj fan that is
the good news right that is the the best
news that you can get right now because
the clock is ticking and uh the win is
not as obvious as we initially thought
uh no certainly not actually kudos to jj
for actually biting the bullet and
allowing
this
king to get checked around
king h7 king h8 you feel like you're one
move away from getting checkmated and
yet you don't
[Music]
so let's try bishop to d5 i don't know
if that's going to improve the position
but let's try bishop to d5
once again king h7 is forced i think you
just play it quickly right
i mean you play this quickly and then
you start thinking so what if i start
with the move c4 oh no no you're not
saying
that's not good
knight 36 is going to be met by
rook takes c3
once again we don't really want rook to
c8
we think that is winning but now
is there a difference my bishop is not
on f7
it feels like i have a bit more air to
breathe around the king
but how can i take advantage of that i
don't see it i just don't see the
difference i i've been struggling to
find a direct continuation for a win i
just cannot find it i think that
you probably have to like bite the
bullet and do something positional we
were talking about
uh what was the positional option though
i i still don't remember the positional
option you don't actually want to go
knight b5 back right that's not
no
not at the end of the world no way
no way
big moment right now
what a huge moment for the tournament
here
devon has been twirling that piece of
hair for the last
20 minutes we've been doing that for the
last like 20 years right it's like the
most telltale sign
that hair is a
big trouble right now i there was an uh
costa rican i am that actually used to
do that on the exact same spot of his
hair yeah and he eventually went bald on
that spout man
that's painful yeah i do not recommend
yeah you cannot do that forever no no no
it's such a bad habit it looks like it's
such a nothing habit but it's actually
such a bad habit
lost in thought down to his last five
minutes that it's just so nerve-wracking
to watch these players
because jj with like an hour on the
clock he's there he knows he's losing
yeah there must be some kind of loss he
doesn't see it either but that's the
thing yeah it's such a good uh thing to
not see the one yeah
right yeah yeah because once you see it
your opponent sees it also somehow yeah
it always happens
like you spot it and your opponent is
like ah he spotted something i can see
it i i see it also did you see what
happened in vishy against uh
of course i mean yeah
same kind of situation right yeah the
moment when she sees it going
well he actually resigned
no that's the thing that's the thing he
resigned but moment didn't know why yes
yes yes
of course he would have seen it 100 said
he would have seen it
so unless that's what everybody says
unless you just take only one
automatically right automatically or
rookie's under attack on e8 the funny
thing is that as one of my students
pointed out yesterday the weird thing
about my media of not noticing queen of
three is that queen of three was already
a threat
all right right because you lose a piece
it was a great take with the queen you
take with the queen but he didn't find
it
he wasn't thinking this is a threat wow
so i don't know maybe he wouldn't have
found it you never know you never know
yeah
down to his last four minutes and 30
seconds
misha antipov needs to make a move right
now
or he's in deep danger
he's putting too much pressure on
himself instead of letting the position
win itself if you don't find an
immediate win just just keep playing
yeah
keep
playing bishop to b3
actually that's a move we did not
consider because it's a relative reason
because the bishop was on v3 that's why
we didn't consider it right
so he didn't actually think for 20
minutes to just repeat the position okay
that's that's one repetition but okay he
gains he gains a minute uh he doesn't
actually get closer to anything there's
no time control and moves 60.
but now immediately
drops to e6
so the chat is asking us how you win but
i mean we've been trying to figure it
out for like 20 minutes we haven't found
it and we cheated for a second we saw
the assessment of the engine the engine
is saying that white is uh dominating
right now but we still could couldn't
find the exact win the bishop b6 played
uh
king h7 played quickly and i do believe
he's knight to d5 or knight to b5
i think knight b5
so he's kind of shuffling nope
kind of shuffle these pieces around a
bit
yes
so now you could take the pawn on a4 if
you want to
as we can see jj is
doubting that this actually works i'm
kind of confused about this yeah chuck
king h is forced
now knight to d6 and if this doesn't
work
if this doesn't work you gave me a lot
of pawns but a lot of pawns what am i
working yeah i could take one but then
looking to d3 and there's no follow-up
knight to f7 is a huge threat
finishes the game in fact
um what if you try to hide your pieces
yeah the idea of bishop c1 would be the
knight f7 check the can go somewhere and
you don't have a discovery you're not
taking anything oh but this is just
checkmate right
so you have to go king g7 king h
that's the same checkmate
so you have to go to g
to g7 sure
i think towards uh yeah but 94 g8 but 95
looks like it's almost made right king
of f8 this is the problem right now but
where's the mate
where is the mate
kind of silly you know but
well i don't think you need a mate
you do so you you you have this option
of uh
in fact winning a piece but
unfortunately your piece also is on pre
yeah yeah you had knight f7 instead of
rook takes c5 and i think maybe that's
good enough
knight to f7
you actually end up losing even more
material after rip takes
and if i do go
to b6 you have knight to c4 yeah then i
pick up
the same yeah wow
incredible
knight to b5 back to the position that
we currently have in
the game and
in fact it's almost 3 p.m right now
central
and he needs to hurry if he wants to
catch his flight oh yeah we're being
told by my student by the way if you go
back to that line yes it is actually
made uh knight g5 later on
you wanted to throw in a check but yeah
knight g5 yeah and knight h7
yeah that's mate yep
knight f6
very nice that's why he's on group a
that's a checkmate
yeah
what a position
what else can we do here because i was
thinking do you start with the move f5
ever i don't know fires are very logical
you could yeah why not i mean is if
you're going to play f5 ever this is the
time to do it get your counter play and
when the rook cannot go to d7 find your
counter play and now
let's go rook to b8 but now knight takes
a4 right some sort of a threat at least
my knight is protected no it's not
that's that's an important point right
it's it's not right now but i can go
king to d3 and that makes it protected
but
will you because i'm like on e4 right
probably not probably not
yeah that's uh it's kind of annoying
actually
so like once again i can give a check
yeah i'll go back
i can now do a very similar type of
routine but it's not quite the same
right
now i go to f1 it seems like the only
place where i don't get a check
perhaps king to e1
knight f7 is still a big threat but even
knight f7 is not that deadly it's not as
deadly as it used to be right it's not
necessarily quite made none of this will
happen because he played the move h5
getting away from a lot of these things
and finally giving h6 to his uh king
actually makes a lot of sense as well so
let's see because once again antipov
seems to be ready for this move
it is a logical move uh it finally gives
black the breathing room of not having
to accept his perpetuals
yes
h5 five minutes from tipoff and
everything to on the line for this
tournament just b group
so what can be played here h6 if you
take on h5 i think black doesn't even
take back right no you take on a4 i
think you just take 184 yeah yeah why
not why not
well even then there is some danger
right rogue d7 because yeah rook 37
knight to d6 so we were actually
discussing this position
maybe rook d7 and maybe hear your take
on the g6 right
why just knight to
knight here but here i start running
with the king yeah
you think you're going to survive that
huh well maybe not immediately maybe
i'll take on c3 first and maybe then
i'll run sure
but then i give you a check
and i get made in a knight f7 i give
knight f7
yeah this is
right but rook takes h6 of course he's
actually played the move rook b8 forcing
me
to move this knight
curious
so
we might he might be forcing us to go
into so let's take a look knight takes
a4
rook b7 king h6 let's say
knight d6
so
that is a threat on f7
what if i take for example on
yes make some more space for the king
knight a4 played uh if knight f7 king h5
finally feels kind of safe
yes right
i'm not convinced actually actually
maybe safe is strong
yeah that's a mate that's meat
that's actually force made right yeah
this is just force mate let's see three
king d3 doesn't help me
let's see where he goes with the king
right now he goes to age six all right
all right so 96 96 being played he's
playing very quickly antipov right now
he seems to have spent those last 20
minutes
calculating it ran away from the board
right now funny guy
so knight f7 group b8 is a huge threat
that's a pretty big threat
by the way one of those situations right
you run away from the board you know you
have imagine he had like
two minutes left on the clock what do
you do as the player that's thinking
knows that the guy just went to the
bathroom
how much time do you give him to spend
in the bathroom and do you make an
immediate move regardless of the
strength of the move and try to take
advantage of that probably not what's
your strategy usually at that point
make good moves
just make good moves yeah over time
um yeah but maybe there's no good moves
that's the thing
that'll be the thing right because this
one is a position that
i would probably think in
just because i feel that i'm not that
lost yet i think it's over you think
it's over yeah it might be i mean this
rook b8 might have been the the thing
that he missed
because it actually just finishes the
game like there's no defense against the
checkmate
and it's easy to see that you make more
space on h5 and then it feels safe right
yeah for a second right then you just
switch the line you get blasted with
this one and there's actually no way
yeah that's the thing you have one check
and that's about it
you can put it in front of it but
there's not even an escape there's no
escape at all no you're not yeah that's
just me made so
let's think uh
anything else bishop c1 knight f7 we
assume is made somehow
this is the the line that
your student
yeah it's it's a little bit different
but it is uh
so bishop to see one knight to f7 king
g7 knight takes e5 this is what we said
with knight g5 on the other
yeah
and the idea was that no you got not h7
now there's without rook on d7 you have
the extra spot on uh i take c3 is on the
board king to d3 most likely
will come i don't not
well
yeah but i mean why wouldn't you play
king d3 right yeah get close to the to
the knight
and then what
there's definitely something brewing
here
some sort of idea that jj has seen
and we have complicate
the position as much as you can
but still so what if i go here knight to
bishop to c1 knight to f bishop to c1
seems almost forced
are we missing anything not really uh
knight f7 king g7 right yes
knight
what if i take on e5
king h6 only move
sad but true because now the rook is not
on d7 right so i have knight d7 against
king f8 97 is coming yeah i agree so you
have to go back
but now what if i just play this
but that doesn't have a threat right
you're escaping yeah oh but
what if i did this
i don't get it
if you take with a king knight f7 is a
mate
so you have to take either with the
bishop or the pawn
not sure with what okay
what do you take with
uh let's say with the pawn
just to okay where you're going with
this
that's disgusting
thank you for taking me the pot that is
gross oh
man
that is that's a visual that is yeah you
don't get that very often that's
beautiful
that's just over here i think so but uh
whatever
all right let's see uh if if we get that
that's gonna be a beautiful end to this
tournament i have to say
all right no
okay let's see bishop to c1 they're
going straight into that line by the way
yes i think so right
he's taking on knight e5 king h6 is the
only move yeah and now he plays gets
busted oh man if he plays king h6 g5
that's beautiful but what about bishop
takes g5
no but they're knight f7 the knight f7
picks up the bishop right this is over
oh come on g5 fg knight g4 is just so
beautiful it is actually beautiful
that's nice that is absolutely beautiful
this whole sequence has been you don't
get that very often
you don't get that ever
you can play your chest on your entire
life you'll never get that i can tell
you that he's gonna
he's gonna
feel yeah the boost of energy after this
game for a very long time when you
finish a game like this it's the last
round of the tournament yeah but you
take it into your next three tournaments
and the next round is very important for
him he's going to be playing vasquez oh
yeah thank you for the playoff yeah 5pm
big moment right now g5
is the killing blow
looking for a tip off to find the move
four minutes
but
g5 and he makes it 35 is on the board
the bishop takes i think is resigns
bishop takes his resume and you have to
take with the pawn
but once again after knight to g4
blocking your last path
to escape
on g4 and bishop to ga there is no more
checks except rook to d5 which just
gives up
yeah there is no way to get to the
defense of the h7 square
he takes with the pawn yeah knight g for
us that's gonna be gorgeous this is just
uh this finishes the game
i'm waiting for antipov i think he sees
it he sees it yeah
he saw it from from a mile away yeah
yeah yeah
one thing about antipov he's very good
with tactics like he's gonna spot this
type of tactics quite easily
and he's a very creative player
that is also why he's very inconsistent
in his play in general
no but he's had actually really
for beautiful stuff here and this
finishes the game
h takes g4 bishop to g8
and that's it and this is it we're going
to have a playoff yep
between
mihail and tipoff who actually started
off with five draws and in the last four
games he scored three and a half
out of four very impressive very
impressive
uh stuff here from a tip of recovering
from what was managed to recover yeah
yeah
big recovery for him and right now look
to c7 only move but i think we're going
to see a resignation
or perhaps you let your opponent give a
checkmate no
yeah beautiful stuff here for michonne
uh catches vasquez at the top so
guillermo vasquez and misha and people
finish the tournament with six points
out of nine i believe uh tied for first
place means we're going to have one
playoff today that would be the playoff
between antiqua van vasquez to determine
the winner of group b here
at the classic what uh what a tournament
so far christian no absolutely uh what
an incredible string of events i have to
say
i did not expect after the first five
rounds with everybody running away it
felt with the beat group especially jj
was running away vasquez was
also felt like running away uh at least
in the leadership a couple of positions
and then
michonne tipoff with five draws came
back he somehow awoken
out of a deep sleep and right now uh six
out of nine going to force on tie breaks
yeah and that'll be very exciting to be
a great show remember to join us at 5
p.m for that one 5 p.m we'll be uh when
we have our tie breaks until then we
still have a couple games left
we do still have a couple of games left
let's see
no samsarin is done with the tournament
actually he was playing robson today
and in fact we do have the only game
left in the a group is actually a
massively complicated game between
oparin and gledura
which might not be so massively
complicated now that i look at it
isn't this completely winning for black
because
queen d5
25 bishop b7
queen
d5 is going to be mad by bishop to b7
if you don't play
queen to d5 then bishop takes h3 might
be a problem as well but and i think we
updated the playoffs format well no
sure we will have a playoffs let's take
a look at what the new format looks like
well we're waiting for the graphic it'll
be here at any moment of course any
moment any moment uh but exciting to
have a play on there we go uh i don't
know about that this looks like the same
graphic is exactly the exact same
gravity
oh my goodness bishop to b7 is a problem
so what can we do what can we do right
now alejandro while the producers
squander their beef
and back in the back let's see um
there's almost a time situation both
sides with 24 minutes so plenty of time
for both of them
that's because they just made time
control okay it does feel like black is
winning but we're not really sure how
just yet
all right
right right where where's where's the
killing blow once again
i haven't found it yet i'm trying to
make something like queen d5 right takes
f2 work or like rick takes f2
immediately but i'm having trouble doing
so
it's not like white has a threat but it
takes history
yeah and i mean it's kind of a threat
right it's not a feels like it's not a
real threat
why not
i mean that's an important pawn for the
attack i think
i um i don't think you can just give it
to me like that i understand you have
other ideas you want to take on f2 and
then play d2 and who knows maybe
try to win like that but
so what if i
play like queen c3 for example queen to
c3 yeah something like that okay so
what if i take what's the i don't know
i'm hoping bishop f2 works what's the
killing blow right now bishop to f2 i
don't know how it works but i'm hoping
that might work actually is that it yeah
d2
sometimes you can actually give up the
queen as the problem
right right so i understand so you go
here
this is just
seems lost right you have bishop g4
still
you do
where's the win
it's kind of funny i don't see it
where is the win is the question
yeah i missed this idea of bishop g4
returning to protect d1 actually all
right so maybe not so easy here let's
take it back
a couple of notches
bishop to c8 current position in the
game
we're not going to cheat on this one
uh people wanted an interview with
antipal but i have bad news for people
uh there's no interviews before playoffs
there is no interviews i i think we
should probably get some tip off here
right um antipop actually it could be
his first interview somehow no he was
already here a couple days ago
i don't think he was yeah he was i
remember him
was he yes
oh
yeah i'm not arguing about this but yeah
uh we'll try to hop on tip off i mean if
he's available around the corner he's
available somebody want to bring him
down to have him
um it is it was a big game and it was a
beautiful game it was a beautiful game i
mean you definitely want to go back
through those those things
i don't think he will mind showing us
that
no no no um
once again
big big game this one between and by the
way these two players are tied right now
in the third position
with a win or pouring would actually tie
for second no way really
recovering out of nowhere i don't know
her right he had such a bad tournament
no he was on minus one and that's true
last one will actually
yeah it'll catch up to mishra you'll
catch up to mishra with lone second high
tie for a second per second
with plus one such a tight event such a
slight event because we'll have a bunch
of people tied then for actually
the the craziest thing well yuya and you
would finish
first obviously
miesha and a parent finish
second and third
with um
four and a half
and the weird thing is played
theodora would finish
clear fourth yeah
with four points with four points
because both gledura and bier
lose samus on three so he doesn't get
any points
sam actually finishes last
wow wow i never saw that going but sam
finishes the sermon last second the
second player in a second rated player
in the event the wow only other 2700
outside of yu yangi
finishes in the last position
it just goes to show how talented all
these players are for sure they're
they're just all so good and uh
sometimes they don't get that elusive
opportunity
uh that we always
always discuss yeah they don't they
don't get that opportunity to prove
their metal and and in this one they
really do i mean this is one of the
beautiful things about the classic
series he's actually played the move
king g7 while we were looking at the
standings
glendora doesn't have as much time as we
thought he actually is down to 10
minutes really yeah oh
down to 10 minutes now we do think that
bishop
takes h3 probably
is the biggest consideration in the
position
but now with the king on g7 and there's
no more rook to
queen to e8 later on in the game
how do you deal with this problem queen
to c3 i wonder what the problem is
though like what is the actual threat
bishop takes f2
which by the way i'm not sure it's a
it's a threat right i mean i'm trying to
figure out why you're so confident that
that's a threat but i haven't
we've been uh discussing that we've also
been here for like two hours without a
break so
i might have to be something new that
yet right all right so bishop to b7 by
the way was played
that makes sense
actually bishop h3 uh rook a6 maybe was
also winning
i was thinking about that that's a very
good point that if you drop the a pawn i
mean the position is just that right
there's no more uh not only that but
rook to a1 is a threat one is just that
yeah yeah that's a problem yeah
that's the big problem and i don't think
you can hide very easily like for
example king
to a g2 and it does seem like the
elusive anti-puff has escaped yeah very
elusive very tricky
and very hard to pin down
why did you give me that visual
you should not have said that rook to a1
queen to e7 and this is just a forced
checkmate
very sad me too actually yeah
all right uh so he that's i think why he
goes bishop b7 uh at least uh not losing
immediately
challenging black to find a threat but
i'm sure that that's not such a
difficult thing to do right
it's quite funny because uh
we had dinner before the game against
beer and obviously
oparin was very disappointed in his
event and
he was asking me how do i win a game you
know
um i said you know this is still a tight
race yeah obviously first place is more
or less out of reach
but everybody's close to each other so
if you win two games the last two then i
think you're going to
not catch up with the leader but finish
very strong
yeah and second thing no chance no
there's no chance i win the next two
games i can
i might as well win the one of them with
the white pieces he was quite confident
about that one but he didn't think that
he would be able to win two games in a
row
and it does feel like he's actually
getting quite close to doing so
yeah what what a comeback for him uh
would be in this tournament what a
result for these players because apart i
mean he was just so quiet in this event
losing so early not winning a game for
what felt like forever and that those 10
rating points were just uh evaporating
ah yeah they just evaporated and he's
got he's coming back and probably not
not even losing rating now no right now
he's on still on minus something right
he's a minus six if it's the door he'll
be on like minus two or one or whatever
something negligible yeah yeah
so uh you know
a big comeback for him
big big comeback for him we know this
collegiate players don't play a lot so
the rating doesn't change that much yeah
they really look for these opportunities
although pirate has been playing quite a
bit
yes this last semester he took advantage
of the fact that he was just about to
graduate
as a graduate student
you already kind of you have your
affairs in order yeah
so the last semester you take it a bit
easier
so interesting uh
in this tournament five players will be
downrating and three will be operating
yeah
yeah very very interesting okay queen
bishop to b7 now how do we
how do we make progress i mean my the
thing i wanted to play a long time ago
was queen c3 and i still don't know why
i cannot play it i'm not a hundred
percent sure what my threat is but
somehow i like my queen here alejandro i
have an idea all right
do you have a threat first of all who
white why i will never make a threat in
this game so what if i go here
my idea is to go here
i asked you if you have a threat and you
said no so i assume this is just losing
right i mean first of all
there wasn't a threat before the rock
was on f5 that is true
[Laughter]
good point
good point
but i play rook five yes you didn't read
my mind you should have that's that was
my mistake i apologize for that one yes
so after rook f5 bishop b4 rook to e5
yeah but here
he's just lost right
it looks lost um
think of this end game
right well
for this
is this
you do have two threatening pawns
at the same time they're not going
anywhere these phones are not going
anywhere
king's getting to d6 pretty quickly okay
so here here
yeah it's just over here here here
here
yeah here and now you're just going to
be able to i just pick up your phone
yeah yeah yeah
yeah
so this one is actually just simply yeah
but i i still like my move queen c3 for
some reason i i don't know i i like it i
have some kind of emotional attack
attachment to this move queezy 3 just
looks right and i can't explain why i
understand i understand uh your
attachment
it does feel like bishop takes f2 is a
threat so
it looks like it but i haven't figured
it out let's make a random move just to
make sure that bishop f3 is so bishop
takes takes d2
you cannot put the queen off the second
uh the first rank because queen c1 is
coming
to stay on b1 or d1 no but queen b1
queen c1 is resigned so so queen d
quintium queen c1 is also resigns that's
then it's results when queen c1 is just
winning right then it resides then
bishop takes f2 after queen c3 is a big
threat
well finally okay so bishop c but queen
c3 has a threat yes
yes bishop f2 is is completely winning
if you allow me to get there
how do you defend and by the way i mean
we're kind of being unfair about
this whole variation
let's just show how
this is completely winning because it
does feel like you have bishop f3 but
unfortunately rupex f3 comes on the
board
rotates f3 is followed by queen to d1
queen is still pinned you cannot take on
f3
and unfortunately at any point king to
e2 is going to be met by rook takes f2
quite straight forward
yeah and if you take on d2 i take and
the rule cannot
take back
big moment right now queen to c3 one
option rook to f5 the other option 17
minutes for a parting to find this one
and
10 minutes for benjamin alejandro i
think as we get ready
for the playoffs we will uh probably
take a break yeah and then we will come
back either with uh
the end of this game or perhaps with the
playoffs directly at 5 pm central time i
think so i think we will
go to the playoffs directly at five
remember two rapid games of game 10 with
a sec a two second delay and now with
the updated graphics of an armageddon
game uh simple simple and easy of five
against four and draw outs with black as
usual uh no increment apparently no
increment after 60 moves that's going to
make it very very exciting um all right
well stay with us or come back to us in
uh just a little bit less than two hours
we will be back at 5 00 p.m central time
with the playoffs in the big group
between vasquez and michonne tipoff
we'll see you in a few yep join us in a
couple hours be there
[Music]
maurice what a pleasure chess in the
parks chess in the parks this is where i
grew up playing chess like for me this
is this is home playing in new york city
playing in brooklyn
prospect park
uh even in manhattan washington square
park it was always a lot of fun oh for
me it's always been like that i've had
the pleasure of playing around the world
in different parks and you get to meet
this real hustlers you can see their
tactics their tricks it's been amazing
and i think new york has the trickiest
ones
man those guys in new york city they've
mastered the art of the hustle first of
all there's always got to be trash
talking like there's no chess without
trash talking we play in the the club we
do commentary in the club and
everybody's quiet and all no
you better take your feelings and park
them somewhere because guys are going to
talk about your mama about your sister
about your best friends and about your
chess moves and you have to be on top of
stuff
i've seen players they're beat up titled
players that come in their confidence
trotting like they know what's going on
they say park players amateurs i can
beat them up i've seen them you know go
home being
just on the receiving end of some nasty
tricks well the legends of the park you
got guys like
vinnie livermore ralph mouth
lightning sam all these guys they knew
how to get inside your head the point is
you think you're playing chess but
you're listening to them at the same
time they know just the right thing to
say to throw you off and there's an art
to that there's an art to distraction
that's what it's all about when you're
playing and then you had like the nasty
tricks sometimes in the old school
jurgers you know the analog clocks
somehow your side would move a little
faster like wait a minute how come my
time is down already or you got the
hustle where when it got down to the
blitz how suddenly all the moves they
made were close to the clock every move
every move was on the side of the clock
so that your flag would fall before
theirs did it was always some kind of
trickery to get your money out of your
pocket money out of your pocket but i
think you've gone around new york how
did it feel the experience of playing
against them man i was playing in the
park and i get my butt kicked
getting my money taking my lunch money
taken by these guys it was just the way
you learned it was just part of being a
chess player in the parks not only also
with the trash talking scene you had a
bunch of guys that's hanging out
sometimes ladies you'd have music
playing you'd be seeing sirens police
cars were going by i'm talking about
this was the hood fulton park as well
and we would just that would be normal
for us so to me that kind of cutthroat
atmosphere
where it was all about winning and you
might get your money taken really
prepared me for what would come when i
was in clubs and you know nobody be
quiet
everything was just high-end yeah for me
it was the same way i grew up a blitz
player i went to in costa rica and i
just played gangsters you know they
would like hustle for absolutely no
money but that was all they had
and i had to learn how to be tricky i
was actually had to slow myself down
when i became a norm hunter because i
was just playing too quickly and too
tricky but it's always been part of my
culture as well and i love going around
the world to different parks and just
seeing
people play luxembourg park absolutely
paris absolutely gorgeous
around moscow you can see people playing
all over i had a great time in avana and
i was just going around the park and i
saw i wasn't even planning on going to
play chess and i was just seeing some
people you know
playing for fun i checked it out man
they were good
man they were solid chess players you
can see the attacks you can see the
tricks they were playing some theory i
was like
not easy anymore part chess can't be
underestimated you know it's funny when
i was playing i remember what the park
players they used to try to play in
tournaments right but even playing in
tournaments they tried to hustle it
right they keep their ratings down they
wouldn't they you know under section
they might you might one or two
sandbaggers might show up all right show
that they could blame the under 2 000
sections under 1800
and try to win money these guys were
2200 strength in blitz but you know it
was funny because they wouldn't be able
to sit still for hours on end they'd be
like yo make a move man because they're
used to going like this so they'd be
sitting there and they'd come out they
would rarely win big money at those
tournaments there was a difference
between park chess and serious
over-the-board tournaments yeah and they
they would tell me to try to keep my
braiding down i was like come on i'm
trying to become a grand master i'm not
going to keep my rating low but it was
always about the hustle and that would
keep them back they it would keep them
back but man they're tricky sometimes
you see them play against strong players
i would say even up to video master
international master level and you'd see
man the 1600 um you know that's not
right so that is absolutely not right
how do they know so many tricks and
sometimes the positional understanding
it's not there it's that flick of the
wrist i'm gonna trip you i'm gonna trick
you and
very dangerous people auto tactics
matter of fact there's a video
of me playing a hustler in washington
square park and he tried to take well i
won't spoil it for people who would
watch it just to say he did a move i'd
never seen tried
ever like ever in the history of my
playing chess and it's after years and
years i mean decades of playing and i
played this thing i saw i was like
this guy actually pulled this hustle
trying to cheat in the middle of a game
and i respected him for it i was like
that was funny like you actually
practiced that and tried to pull it off
he could have done it a lot better i
still would have seen it but it was a
great great move
i i think it's just a resourcefulness
when it comes down to it the practice of
being resourceful at so many different
things in chess and i love the
creativity they bring to it it's the
clock it's the tactic it's the it's the
doom i'm not really sure we're in the
pieces i love that one it could be on
two four squares at once four squares no
my bishop just changed color what are
you talking about in the middle you're
like wait how did that bishop i thought
it was a white square bishop now it's a
dark square bishop stuff like that is
just priceless and you gotta land for to
fend for yourself nobody's to be like
yeah of course that bishop no you got to
fight for your rights in those games
there's no arbiter to call over hey
chris bird can i have some adjournment
no
no
you're in the middle of the war and it's
fun like i said the trash talking
uh the the music
the joy of the game the fun of it and
the cutthroat aspect you'll see people
standing around a chessboard in a park
and watching
like they're watching magnus cross and
play hikaru nakamura because people are
showing off it's the when hikaru and
magnus and all these guys they play a
brilliant move you know they played and
they they might adjust their piece a
little bit more than another you're at a
party like boom baby i'm here to play
chess come watch i'm playing this
brilliancy it's just a different
atmosphere and the language uh will get
a little um
you know let's just say we can't talk
talk about that when we're at the st
louis chess club but
the flamboyance and the language guys
would be quoting shakespeare
like who's this guy and they're mixing
in street with
old school classical
everything it's just i think i think it
would make a great show
if it was all about park chess it would
i think i made great tv maurice i'm
getting fired up let's let's play some
chances let's do this
this is i feel like i'm back back and
you can't even make moves man come on
you're trying to cheat me i'm nervous
nervous just making me nervous play
chess look at this guy you name it hack
it give me a break this is a boring this
is how you play chess oh my sister plays
better than this she don't even know how
to play chess do you want the best from
the fourth record
that
[Music]
do you know how to pass the fourth rank
hey man well i tell you maurice i got
really strong feelings
about the topic
of
how chess
the generation of today
versus our generation old school versus
new school years old school versus new
school
young don't know anything about the old
school stuff
but you know this is it this is where i
got the strong strong feelings but mixed
feelings
like
i love
the fact
that i had a germans i learned so much
through analysis and studying
and doing myself chess was a mystery
right it was a mystery it was great
a lot of times we didn't know what was
really going on we didn't we didn't we
had to press ourselves and really dig
deep into the position
and
i missed having an opponent i really did
i was like i was 12 13 when i got
started nobody wanted to beat up on me
but nobody wanted to lose either so i
was like always sitting watching
because from afar because i couldn't get
a game right
now you got an opponent 24 hours a day
anytime you not just an opponent
[Music]
getting the games the data you know like
the bulletins of the soviet championship
that was like
oh three months later three minutes
later you thought about some game right
that was played somewhere in moscow or
nick sichu or some place in the world
right and nowadays it's automatic it's
it's it's live when you get it six
million database of games i you did six
million it's like eight nine million now
yeah where are you
it's unbelievable so i'm in insanely
jealous of
the kids of today the generations today
all the tools they have the internet
chess was different maurice chess was
different uh gary kasparov said it well
the other day blitz chess was five zip
threes it if you were a maniac you know
you're three three you mean no
increments no no
time was the time the hands were like
this shaking you're right you're banging
clock yeah
wait a minute fix the pieces right what
are you doing on your time and you
didn't know how much time you had left
today
how much time i got
like
and then you made the time control you
made the time control
and the flag never fell like one minute
two three minutes you had been bashing
the clock like nothing and like you had
more time than you thought no nowadays
they know to the to the tenth of a
second right how much time they had left
and the thing is
even just the idea of studying books
right books books what are books tyro
doesn't look at books you look at books
he has the databases they got the
engines
that's it you just ask the engine what's
the right move here exactly you don't
need somebody to tell you that the
principle in this position is to control
the center
right a break in the middle the computer
says screw your break in the middle
it's mating six right this wins that's
it you're you're talking nonsense that's
what uh lavonne had said in an interview
he says
i don't want to spend
20 hours studying an open
i want to hit
my
bars me the answer
and
space
like you know people spent i want to say
lives but that's like a look studying
you know what i'm talking about the
sicilian dragon that was their pet if
you they couldn't play the sicilian
dragon they weren't interested in
playing nope and they put
everything their heart and soul into an
opening and today they dropped those
openings like nothing man i got no
commitment to you if you're not
producing the result go and back in the
day you stuck to like three or four very
fearful openings that was a lot that was
a lot like this is what this is what you
play
you know if you play the carrot con
that's
that's what you do that's it now you see
these guys play six or seven different
things and you know them well like this
is like i could be the sicilian i could
play the camera i could play the french
i might throw modern at you right you
never know
toss out an alicon and do something
crazy he said how are these guys playing
all these things and they know the
theory they they only quote the game
even if the game was played a week ago
right got it yeah this was just played
it's incredible just a touch of the
button and the thing though that's got
to scare you
or maybe it frustrates me is when they
start looking at the classics and saying
the classics like why
those guys didn't know what they were
doing like they made all of these
mistakes the engine shows alekhine's
combination was unsound
even though
even though it took years for people to
really analyze the combination was it
sound was it unsound quick story quick
story two guys victor korchner tieger
and petrosian hated each other i mean
intense this was like the rivalry to end
rivalries and i was victor korchnoy's
coach
and they got together for a candidate
match
a couple draws a couple of draws an
adjournment
and they got to this crazy position
courtney thought he was winning and i
said victor you got to play g4 no no no
no no ain't playing g4 ain't happening
no no no g4 is terrible we look
good petrosian took a timeout we spent
24 hours seriously
michael steen myself victor we worked
hard intensely on this adjourned
position he said
victor you got to play chief
i caught him in a moment of weakness
horrible move rook c8
you lose
okay he played the right move h6 h4 he
made the wrong move bang bang bang you
lose
finally he plays all the right moves and
it's a draw he says see it's a draw
i go yeah but i think the positions are
dry was it queen versus two bishops
we go to the playing hall and said
victor you're going to play g4 you know
i go sit down in the audience back back
bling hall dark
and
victor gets to the position instantly
plays g4 it's the clock
i want to stand up and cheer yeah that's
my move everybody you know applaud me
that's what i did what i did sit down
petrosian
writes down and move ten minutes passes
it doesn't make a move another ten
minutes pass petrosian doesn't make a
move
35 minutes pass before petrosian makes a
move
and during that 35 minutes
i went through
hell
torment
stone cold absolute fear what
if i had made a mistake in my analysis
and korchner loses
to his most hated
rival this would be terrible right
so i'm in like
after 35 minutes i'm in a trembling
panic
petrosdian plays rook c8 the first move
that victor played against me bang bang
bang bang
victor won
would have been the best move or the
worst move or the right answer that's
why adjournments had to get booted out
right just because of engines now and
you look at openings that used to be
garbage back in the day right
rehab for sure all of a sudden white had
all these advantages back in the day
evaporating in smoke right how
do you think that that
has taken something away from modern
chess has it made it less rich less
interesting
or
or do the players just simply have to be
more creative
yes and yes that's the crazy part it
seems to me that chess evolves with
these new tools whatever they are the
internet increment just evolves yeah for
me i love the mystery of chess okay
that's taken away but look what has come
in its place
these guys play chess more accurately
today than ever that's the truth the
quality of the games are remarkable
incredible they are you know what let's
play
like the old school days yeah baby move
it
i'm gonna follow yesterday's advice oh
yeah you know you're scared of this in
english you this is what you play
english okay let's go carp
baby you remember them days playing car
paw oh it was so much fun it was sweet
it was sweet he's building a fortress i
haven't even come over to kids
let me do one of your
favorites
okay alejandro
what have you done
during this pandemic
well
i have to tell you the pandemic came
just such a huge shock right for
everybody for everybody and the chess
world was affected in many ways i have
to say some positive and some negative
of course as soon as the pandemic hit
everything was canceled
right we had all these plans the us
championship was about to come up in
2020 we had a lot of team tournaments
going on it was the pan
american
national championship pan ams are april
right actually pan ams are in december
and we qualified for the final four the
national championship that's what i
meant the national championship for the
universities in san luis university was
of course qualified ready to compete
with the best here
and suddenly
we just didn't have the ability to
travel
all over
all cancelled
wow that was a tough blow but luckily
for us in our sport we were able to move
it online okay very nice
we weren't able to manage to make the
final four online so that was cancelled
as well but slowly slowly we started
getting more tournaments and i'm happy
to say that missouri has two world
champions not only that st louis
university win the world university
blitz championship
but mizzou missouri university headed by
christian kirilla they won the rapid
protection
congratulations so
you guys ended up being world champions
right
so cool a tournament that had never been
hosted before because of the pandemic
video was well we can host it online
that makes it kind of easy nice very
nice the st louis university your
foreign students
they must have been terribly impacted in
all kinds of ways they had a tough
decision to make of course there were
lockdowns around the world and some of
them were unable to travel to america
okay
they weren't able to attend classes in
person everything was moved online they
had a tough decision to make do you want
to take online classes from here or do
you want to do it from your home country
and some of them were just unable to
travel at all even if they had the
desire to come to america we had visa
issues we had closed borders it was just
difficult for them and i have to say it
was a very very tough first semester
there with the pandemic and slowly
everything was moved online we were able
to get zoom meetings we were able to
move all of our classes online i met
with everybody through skype or zoom
and then you had something soon then you
had some students that may have been
trapped on campus like they can't
necessarily go home or can't necessarily
return to their own countries so they
had to stay in the dorms and right we
hadn't
wasn't too pleasant either right oh we
had quarantined periods a couple of my
students actually they had to quarantine
at a hotel for 14 days without leaving
the room oh dear just to come for
university yeah oh my gosh it was very
hard
but
things are easing up a little bit we do
have tournaments now which is
it's a big plus a lot of my students
they were norm hunting okay they were
trying to get that elusive grand master
title they had a whole schedule planned
i'm gonna get my first norm here my
second norm there and my next crack is
going to be there
that's all smashed away snatched away
and they had to just be patient and keep
their skills sharp by playing online
because well there were certainly no
norm tournaments right right so
a lot of them
they said i have to wait i'm gonna make
myself an online specialist for now but
it's just not the same exactly online
unlike over the board
over the board i can play you a
four-hour game oh it's gonna have it and
it's gonna be a cool game and i'm gonna
learn a lot i am not going to play you a
four-hour game online i i may play
41-minute games online but somehow
online chass is not conducive to
classical chess it's more blitz
it's the arena for blitz and rapid and i
think i get this asked a lot especially
by amateurs like why don't grandmasters
play classical chess online why don't
they it's boring
it's just straight up boring i mean if
you have a tournament and you're playing
for something of course you add to the
mix and we had several classical
tournaments online
during the pandemic but it doesn't have
that feel it's just weird when you're
not in front of the board i can't see
you i can't make you uncomfortable right
the clock is ticking
no trembling hand you know and somehow
when you're playing classical chess
online you have to sit in front of the
computer for 35 minutes waiting for your
opponent to make a move right
it's just like time's not passing right
and somehow when you're in front of the
board 35-minute thing by your opponent
passes in a snap it can easily go easily
so it's just not conducive and i think a
lot of grand masters don't like it and
some of them just flat out refuse
exactly i i'm not interested at all in
classical chess but
online
but then it's the funny part the
opposite happens
when we are at over the board tournament
uh we we just had the rapid and blitz
which i really really enjoyed
but i'm even more looking forward to the
zinc fill cup which is a classical time
control where the players really
sit down and they carefully craft their
plans i have to say that i'm a huge fan
of rapid chess specifically i think it's
this wonderful mix of fast but also
something that can be explained to the
public we have time to go through the
games and explain their combinations and
their thought process and they still
have the time to calculate brilliancies
right but there is no substitute for
classical chess right it just has this
magic where you see these brilliant
preparations where you see that every
move needs to be precise and of course
the level of chess is so high now that
yes we do see a significant amount of
draws yes we do see a lot of games peter
out but that magic of this brilliant
classical chess it really can't
be explained and it cannot be replicated
in any other format right
uh for me i just have to say that i like
the grand chess tour a lot this hybrid
format this combination of blitz and
rapid in a in a contained tournament
then the classical the only thing to my
mind
that is missing about the grand chess
tour
we need more events we do need more
events that's it but they are coming we
do have more and more events planned in
the grand chess tour and we've had so
many join now we have traditionally the
paris tournament i think that was such a
great addition to the tour and we're
gonna have so many coming up but i have
to agree with you the hybrid i love it
you have the best players in the world
not just in classical not just in rapid
and blitz you have to prove that you're
good at every format to be able to win
the gran chester and i think that's
what's made every tour winner so far
stand out absolutely
well thank you yasser absolutely again
dude let's go
we're in the park it's time to make a
hustle
i know this one yeah i know this
one no
don't do it
oh
surprising me there
oh man i hate those hot cacitos
[Music]
yo yo yo yo back in
st louis at the st louis chess club yes
sir i want to talk about
presentation presenting chess
presenting chess over the years i mean
it has evolved it's changed so much you
know nowadays we got everything
we got computers right we've got
all the cameras that are showing players
from multiple angles internet video
it's like audio i can't even imagine if
i was able to sit and watch yesterday
and the us chess championship had video
of that to be able to watch it live
instantly no back in the day
they had the
the kids in the russian i remember you
know they show this in the queen's
gambit they're
actually hooking chess pieces and
putting them on these giant boards
that's right for people to follow right
but the real original i think great
great presentation for chess
was shelby lyman calling fisher spassky
pbs on pbs tell us about it well first
of all it was like from russia with love
the james bond movie
where you know the the evil character is
playing chess and you're right it's
it's the
moving of the pieces on the stick and
there's no commentary it's just like
everybody whispering oh my gosh that's a
good move
they got their sets
shelby live and
revolutionized
chess in america chess on tv
and it was hilarious because now we
watch it we go oh my god that's terrible
the guy would say stop what we're doing
he's not the the telefax machine is it's
spitting out a move and everybody run to
the machine and go oh my god shelby had
pieces in his pocket he forgot to put
back on the board it was amateur hour
and america loved it they had never
chess was greek
jesus is greek and here's a guy
talking
about
how important the pawn was you can't
lose that bud if you lose the pawn
maurice you're going to lose influence
over here and this was at the time when
fischer was playing against basketball
exactly the cold war era yeah maverick
america the soviet dominance and he
played into that as well as the whole
fever of chess in america
was ready for that kind of commentary
page news it was amazing no i mean it's
ridiculous walter cronkite
the voice of american news he would
start his presentation about the great
stories of the day boom boom boom boom
boom but before we get into those
stories
bobby fischer is leasing his magic boris
excuse he's number three and we're going
to go into reykjavik and get an update
amazing it was like what and this is
fantastic and as a result of that of
course a slew of grandmasters came along
yourself and benjamin is the bobby and
the generation but we jump ahead and we
go to
my first time doing commentary i'm in
the kremlin in moscow the first sporting
event ever held in the kremlin who does
a sporting event in this political
institution right but the intel world
chess grand prix gets a sponsorship
kasparov is able to get that pull as the
world champion and we're in the kremlin
i'm there for eurosport
with danny
this is before danny king and i actually
tape and we're sitting there bob rice
who's the president of the
professional chess association
he says to me maurice
the russians are doing commentary we
americans we can't understand anything
would you mind going up in a booth and
just talking and explaining the games
just so that we can follow kasparov and
kramnik on stage for the foreign foreign
visitors so i go up they hook me up in
this old school
booth i'm like what's going on i'm by
myself i got on the headset i got the
microphone i'm looking down on the stage
and gary's playing crom nick and i
decide i'm not doing commentary like old
school commentary
i'm gonna do it like john madden and
mark albert
like like it's pro sports right so i'm
shouting at the top of my lungs by
myself in the room so whatever and i'm
going oh my god
did you see what he missed this is
unbelievable right i hear that clara
kasparova later the mother mother of
gary
she can't speak any english but the
sound coming from my voice through
everybody else's headset earpiece that
they're listening you know was so
dynamic and interesting that she changed
from russian to english just to listen
to me modulating up and down so she
could be excited about the game just the
drama of it that's how i started that's
fanta that's a fantastic story
nothing similar but there's something i
love there was a match between
um
deep fritz
and vladimir kramnik in bonn germany
and you know
germany
so they had german commentators a whole
group of them
and the germans thought well
okay we're going to have one english
commentary one english we have like r2
yusuf klaus bishop uh helmuth lager all
of these germans all lined up and there
was me like you in the one booth
so i did my commentary and unfortunately
for vladimir he lost to the computer the
deep that was the checkmate in one year
i go down the escalator
and this german man with the heaviest
german accent says mr
chervan
thank you thank you
i i
change
digit
i listen you
english very good
english
schwein nietzsche
and i got
the the bottom line is people
were not only interested in the chess
but they were also interested in how you
present the english and the english
words
a lot of kids have come up to me and
said i learned how to pronounce naidor
or anpris
or
fianchetto the enchant though from you
and i was like what
i'm the worst the basic
what you would think
and you know you talk about that even in
this digital age where now we have all
these presentations in fancy ways and
cameras and multiple angles you still
get characters and you taught me about a
character
a commentator who has this distinctive
voice oh my gosh
the way he presented charger please tell
us that was terrible terrible terrible
so sharjah in the united arab emirates
was hosting
the world blitz
championships the world rapid
championships and they poured all their
money all their resources
into the playing hall the prize fund the
hotels the ambiance and somebody said
oh my gosh we're gonna
show the games live
you know just the moves but maybe we
should get a commentator
so there was a grand master in residence
at the sharjah chess club and it's sort
of like
we he didn't even know it but he was put
there well i've got to tell you
something
i mean i'll he'll go nameless but i just
have to say he was the worst commentator
i've ever heard my life and he would be
talking like this
oh you see mob news mark news look how
he played
two bishops so nice oh my god what'd he
do he give it two bishops why
magnus he know he understands
i was like
you could have come over here this was
great we were laughing
the guy became a cult figure
because he was just so
love it well awful get started okay
let's do commentary yeah you're playing
a sicilian oh come on
that's right
you don't accept them
that's a cereal you should be ashamed of
yourself oh yeah
boring chess i can't believe this we got
to go into moroxy vine
oh my god i can't believe
look at this guy this is the guy i'm
just gonna cackle
yo man what's up what's up listen we're
here in front of the saint louis chess
club
and uh it's the world famous club as you
know we live here all the time but there
are great clubs all around the world
absolutely and i gotta say there's great
clubs in new york city
yeah for sure i just played on a lot of
them you got to talk new york city the
marshall chess club i was champion of
the marshall chester let me just humble
no right
absolutely uh you know that club was
pretty strong and somehow i managed to
win a championship there
but
the importance of clubs
for chess especially now
in the digital age
yeah in the past you couldn't overstate
the importance of the club the club
was the place it's the hub man that's
where everybody went that's where we
talked to each other do you know about
the russian championships you got the
bulletins we traded books we traded
stories we analyzed we played so the
clubs
especially in the 70s 80s 90s man that
was the gathering place
and in
on the west coast we had a marvelous
club the mechanics chess club san
francisco i've been there did lectures
played there
and
that club from the 1850s
right still a vibrant place today that's
like a marvelous place in new york what
was your favorite hangout well you know
like you said without the clubs how do
you find players exactly i remember
going to the manhattan chess club the
manhattan chess club no longer exists
now but it was an institution in fact
the manhattan moved into the carnegie
hall building exactly like you know you
were on the 10th when you arrive
as a musician you go to carnegie hall of
course when you arrive at the chess
player you go to the manhattan chess
club exactly
i remember going into the manhattan club
and you you've got all these famous
grand masters in there and we'd have
friday night blitz right and i would
have played in those two i would walk in
right and i remember once i walked into
the friday night blitz and you know
there was a steve emmett the tournament
director and i said jeffrey kastner no
in particular i remember steve inman
when i walked in and i said to steve
who's playing in the blitz tonight
and he says to me no he says to me you
can't ask who's playing in the blitz and
then not play he thought i was trying
you know
get a fast one hustle right i said to
him
i only want to play if there's strong
players playing
and he's shot he's like well we've got
benjamin we've got fed we got deluge
sign me up i'm in that's the kind of
strength level you had at that club you
always wanted to play so it allowed me
to get stronger as a player if there
were no clubs there was no internet and
stuff to to
be able to just jump on and get a strong
player anytime you want you needed a
club in order to make that happen no
question about it and for me
and seattle when i was growing up we had
the american chess service the acs and
we had a guy organizer there's always
one organizer who is you know like there
all the time robert anthony carts we
called him rack
and rack organized tournaments i am not
kidding nearly every weekend
congresses i remember playing in these
you know any kind of holiday there was a
thanksgiving day tournament there was a
columbus day tournament there was a
president's day open you know all of
these tournaments and that's where i got
strong that's where i cut my teeth and
you know sharpened my game and
where i actually met all my friends now
today you want to talk about a digital
age my gosh
it's all online which has been good in
many ways but i miss this
the camaraderie at the club move you
know i'm thinking about i'm thinking
about old school clubs like the flea
house oh brilliant you know my my good
homeboy willie johnson pop he's telling
me about the days in the fleet house
where he's coming up he see uh ginger
josh really hanging out and those
players you know about the fleet house
oh gosh yes uh
okay i go there in 1977 i'm 17 years old
as strong as an og surfer swimmers build
long hair
afro actually here
come in
and the guy says to me you look like
you're looking for something what are
you looking for
it's a chess game
social or for money
i play for a little money come with me
brings me to the table
guys guys holding court
got a new customer says the guy says
where you from i go seattle
go seattle
that's close to alaska
alaska
gets night out
now understand me
at that exact moment in my life
there was one possibly two people in the
entire united states who could play even
with me they were walter brown and
bernard zuckerman and that was it
everybody else if i don't recognize
bernard's look
or walter brown you're toast
guys giving me night off it's
unbelievable it's unbelievable i don't
know what i did marie seriously i was
just like lollygagging and i don't know
because there were side bets going on i
got confused i lost the game what the
last game was knight odds
game
the best thing i could possibly do
everybody jumped on the next game i
wiped them out wiped them out wiped them
out we played even
but he gave me time odds three to one i
wiped them out wiped them out we played
even three to three i wiped him out
wiped him out i gave him three to one
he says come tomorrow
i show it the next day asa hoffman comes
that's their champion asa took one
no we're going out to dinner i'm going
to teach you treat your raised pizza
you're going to wipe me out
and everybody in the flea house
he's a kid
that's an
of a club that is very little known the
kingsman chess club don't know what no
the kingsman chess club were a group of
largely african-american players in
brooklyn i ended up growing up with
people who were from the kingsman chess
club the black bear school yes but the
kingsman chess club they were some
serious players and as a young expert
budding master i would play against
these guys and
john evans i remember uh
of course willie johnson was a part of
it
and it was because of a club like that
that you could go to that you could say
here's a serious player right here
people you could sit down it wasn't just
blitz it was even over the board but
casual over the board right you don't do
that nowadays nobody sits down and plays
games without clocks and time no no way
in the world but it was a place like
that where i could go and grow as a
young african-american in brooklyn right
without that club
i don't graduate and add to everything
you said you play a wonderful game
and then the guy says no man i was doing
great let's just i should have played
this
and you analyze and the next thing you
know you start appreciating the fact
that you missed ideas somebody else
spectators come in and they go no no no
that was fun yeah the fun part of course
is as you said the kabitsu is on the
side
hey why didn't you do this everybody's
200 points stronger when they're on the
side and they're just talking and you're
you know what what do you mean this and
that and that kind of camaraderie how do
you find it in a digital age you just
don't it's
that is a lost art and i used to love
that about the analysis everybody's
hands on the board right you got to have
rules now you can't put your hand if you
touch the board you got to put money you
have to put money
forget about it right that's the kind of
stuff you just miss when you're always
doing it on a computer online no
question about it that
that's the downside there was one
downside of a club i just got to mention
i had a club that i went to uh and i
cycled to the club
and frankly speaking it was 20 minutes
to get to the club but that was downhill
it was an hour coming back
up the hill you get to the club and
there was nobody to play oh that's
that's the tough part i agree nobody to
play digital age is quite different you
always have somebody exactly and it's a
great thing to have some place like the
st louis chess club oh my goodness where
everyone can come and enjoy a game and
the best part there's people like yester
cyril on maurice ashley a christian
gorilla and alejandro ramirez grand
masters everywhere absolutely
always nice always nice
let's play let's play
oh man this
this is getting good right okay
chinese variance no i don't know that
stuff yeah that's too modern
um
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
um
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
um
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
this
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
this
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
bye
[Music]
[Music]
2022 summer chess classic and i'm
alejandra ramirez here with christian
carrillo to bring you the thai bricks
christian we have a tie in group b oh
yes we do so group a of course uh was
finalized earlier in the day you young
he cliched the title took home six
thousand dollars and the championship
but we still have group b and uh what a
finish it was in group b we had the very
important match between antipov who was
trailing the leaders uh that is jj
alimorandi by half a point he had to win
in order to force a tie breaks against
himself and vasquez and he did in
spectacular fashion that was right now
we do have a big tie breaks between
vasquez and michonne people yeah let's
take a look at the standings for the
thurmans let's actually start with the
group a uh pretty straight forward here
actually a dominant performance by
chinese player yu yang yi he escorts a
brilliant six out of eight remember that
we did have a drop out from the
tournament as ray robinson wasn't able
to finish grigoria fire and anna bimanu
mishra both having very different
tournaments i mean you're actually
starting pretty strong and gregory uh
returning to strength
from a weekend position at the first
half of the tournament both end with a
plus one four and a half score excellent
event for abimanu's certainly also an
excellent event from nicolas diodoro who
finishes his tournament 50
one of the two lower rated players of
the event he certainly must be happy
with that one and meanwhile with three
and a half points we have actually a big
tie benjamin ledoux adam jacobian jonas
bier who must be quite disappointed with
the tournament considering his standing
only two rounds ago he lost two rounds
in a row two hours in a row it's not uh
definitely it can't be feeling good uh
elias mirren also with three and a half
points and sam savion actually probably
the most disappointed player from this
event uh finishing on a on a very
weekend three out of eight no absolutely
and uh let's see what happened up to
this point in the b group in the big
group we have misha antipov and
guillermo vasquez who uh both scored six
points out of nine they will be playing
a playoff in just a few minutes kamil
dragoon jj alimarandi tied for third
position in seoul fifth we have
christopher you who actually won his
last game and scores five points out of
nine tied for six we have zoo jean chao
who flagged in the last game against
christopher you uh ty's with john john
burke actually you are right alejandro
against uh checker who is in eighth
position the gran harold
had a horrendous event he lost today uh
and uh is sitting in ninth position and
of course brandon jacobson who had to
withdraw after five rounds in ten
position
yeah so we're just waiting uh biting our
time really for this to start uh
guillermo vazquez is we will be playing
with the white pieces to start off his
match against michonne tipoff that was
decided completely randomly uh we can go
over the format for this playoff as we
are about to get started it's pretty
straightforward as we have the graphic
here uh two game rapid matchup for game
plus two with the two second brunch
staying delayed
uh i don't know why we're using the
light but we're using delay and if tied
the match will be decided by an
armageddon game and that one of course
is the traditional five versus four with
black winning in case of a draw no
increment at all in that one
yes and that is quite unusual right
because in general we get an increment
after 60 moves at move 61 both players
start getting uh two seconds increment
unfortunately well for the player i
would assume with the black pieces in
this case he will not have that option
to rely on so yeah the game had to has
to be finished uh before that yeah and
we've been trying new armageddons and
as my camera there is finishing up the
rules for the players uh i think they've
been trying all kinds of armageddon's
recently i mean norway has just tried a
completely different type of armageddon
than we're used to with the 10 minute
against i think
seven
but you get one second increment from
40. right the players
i think we're not a huge fan of
no 10 10 minutes versus seven minutes
and then you get an additional increment
increment after only 40 moves that seems
a bit lower yeah but the one second was
nothing yeah one second is not a lot
that is true so if you are building up
an advantage as white in that case you
still have quite a significant advantage
in time yeah on time all right you see
my cover there
international arbiter of course the
international arbiter for this event
uh
finalizing the rules here
absolutely and
let's not forget the mission depot
actually this might be one of his first
events where he's playing with delay
that is funny actually i don't know if
vasquez has played used delay too well
vazquez has been in the united states
for a while yeah but when was the last
time that you saw delay in the american
tournament right now that's a question
but still he's been here for a very long
time so i assumed that perhaps he had
the option of playing uh michonne tipple
only came to the united states in march
this year so much this year hasn't had a
lot of time to experience with delane he
is asking some questions right now yeah
and quite honestly delay is something
that only exists
here in north america yeah i've never
seen it anywhere else i i haven't heard
of it before i moved here as uh as well
all right let's see and these players
actually know each other quite well
because they've been playing a lot in
collegiate events we've seen them battle
it all out in uh world collegiate
championships individual end team and i
have to say that vasquez especially in
online games
has quite the upper hand against misha
and tipoff yes he beat him quite a few
times
oh no
take a look at that so i know that misho
is definitely looking to get some sort
of a revenge
d3 how did they do in their uh
e5 we discussed this a long time ago oh
really yeah he plays this uh vasquez
there is he plays it online all the time
d3 and e5 what if you take that pawn d4
oh wow
all right
let's see this prep the prep is coming
let's see let's see he he analyzed this
recently so we'll see for
it it must not be super pleasant to
actually face this over the board with
the white pieces yeah yeah let's uh
you know i'm sure vasquez has some ideas
in this case because he's been playing
it a lot online a3 a3 passive move but
it does prevent bishops
yeah bishop b4 is a
big issue right now you have the option
of going bishop to g3 or you can go even
bishop to f4 and try to
perhaps get the bishop back to b2 bishop
f4 bishop c1 bishop b2 guarantee the
things that won't happen bishop all the
way back to g3 so black is basically
just down a pawn but in exchange he has
tons of development
and he's made a lot of useful moves
whereas black white's moves
not as useful right this bishop has been
hopping around a3 b3 d3 also not as
useful as developing knights opening up
your files and bishops so certainly
compensation is that enough
that is a very good question and now
with the bishop g3 we do see uh the ink
capability of white to actually develop
the light square bishop via g3g bishop
g2 the fianchetto bishop so assume e4 at
some point e4 has to be played for that
reason i'm looking to perhaps stop you
or at least try to stop you from doing
that with either bishop cc5 no bishop c5
looks very logical at this position it's
annoying to get this bishop on f1 back
into the action exactly yeah bishop to
c5
would be my initial instinct now of
course you put the bishop on c5 then b4
could potentially come on the board
followed by
knight to d2 and knight to c4 if you
decide to put the bishop on b6 i have to
target
the dark square bishop and at some point
make e4 or e3 possible
in the meantime of course
black is going to finish his development
try to
focus uh his cannons the rooks on the e
and d files and try to put pressure in
the center
yeah this is a great one actually
this is a great sacrifice i really like
it uh not so much of a fan of his time
management though i it's been an issue i
think for antipov it doesn't really
matter what time type of chess he plays
where he spends a little bit more time
than i would like for him to do
something
bishop c5 played it was something that
you could have played
instantly recently and then they figured
it out right
and let's see i do see that vasquez
replied immediately with before as we
anticipated yes bishop to b6 so they're
kind of going into that variation that
we discussed and c4 now yeah c4 was a
big question it does look a bit risky
because i could even take on c3
but you might have to right well as
black you mean right because c5 is
coming c5 is might be a problem
yeah maybe there's no option
but i don't think there's an issue right
like you can take and castle or
something like this castle and what if i
go e3 now
but that's the thing right if i manage
to stabilize the position i am a pawn up
if i if i get bishop p2 castle i can
consider myself almost in a winning
position yeah you're super thrilled with
the position then you've got a great
sicilian and the extra pawn no i agree
with you but if you don't take you don't
have too many things to do he's taken on
c3 so maybe he needs something more
immediate here
but what is it because f2 is covered
which is important in many variations
somehow knight d4 for example f2 is
always covered as it is
he's losing momentum i feel you feel so
right um unless he finds something
immediately
this position is starting to look like
black is losing some momentum and he
he's done it he has to find something
he has to create some imbalances and he
does so with the move a5 a5 probably b5
has to be played
in the absence of the dark square bishop
on the queen side you cannot really take
on a5 and allow bishop takes a5 no not
at all so b5 knight to d4 is on the
board
now the most logical move is to go e3 e3
of course an issue for it right now
takes you can take with the queen
and i taking advantage of the fact that
d3 is kind of defended because i could
play rook d1 and you're pinned perhaps
even castle perhaps even castle if you
want to be fancy about it why not yeah
actually why not uh knight xd4 is on the
board by the way really yes very curious
why not e3
queen takes or bishop takes is the
question
that misha is right now queen takes i
like queen takes yeah i think he did yes
i i i also like it uh rook c1 i assume
is played here right
roxy one or queen to d2 are going to c2
you have actually a lot of options to c1
i like rexy one because there's no other
file for the rook to go that's so
obvious get the rook off
yeah yeah
for a lot of reasons i like this better
um once again
white is one move away e3 bishop p2 yeah
stabilizes the position completely
actually yeah so black has to once again
find something
and he plays a4 four all right so make
some sense you want to open up e5 queen
c5 this feels
right
try to target the bottom a3 bishop to a5
is also an attempt at creating some
imbalances
how do you continue this one and by the
way e3 queen c5 is on board maybe you
should just play bishop e2 here
and
if i take and go castle finally castle
yeah you do get your pawn back as black
which is huge i'm not going to say it's
not but i start lacking white's
strategical center queen c2 rook a1 is
going to be a threat against the pawn on
a4
it really comes the position really
comes down to whether the power on a4 is
more of an asset or a liability exactly
and
it feels like it's more of a liability
for the moment at least yes so now the
question is after bishop to e2 can i
start with the move bishop to a5 and
does that
help me at all it might because the idea
is that on castles bishop takes c3 it
looks like i do have a pin on you but
how do i exploit it because maybe queen
c2 i just don't know
ideas nevertheless i mean e4 before
such a complicated battle right now yeah
but it didn't look like it was going in
black's direction no and the problem is
in the absence of the bishop on
b6 pawn on c7 is extremely extremely
weak yeah yeah so i was looking at ideas
of exchanging the queens but now
it just doesn't look good now the power
bishop was too strong in this position
right there of bishops the pawn on c7 is
going to fall very soon and the power on
a4 honestly is
and he played it he played bishop too
yeah i think i think it's a very logical
move
you don't want to you couldn't even
defend the a3 i think you
know like last job uh white job is
easier because you just can't the only
way to defend it would be with knight b1
but then
you give up b5 who plays that right
no bishop e2 makes a lot of sense uh you
have some moves queen takes a3 i think
was
played and castle is that yeah queenie
three castle on something but i couldn't
see whatever yes queen a3 castle and
knight d7
right is redirecting um
b3 yes if you can manage to get to b3 i
think you will be quite happy what does
knight d5 here
that's a very
pertinent question
he decided not to play that really
okay unfortunately my board is not
updating so perhaps we can see the
actual
the actual bird's eye view knight to d7
why do i feel like i'm down at tempo
because we are
how how do we
how did we get here
okay wait what queen c5 bishop e2 takes
on a3 castles knight d7 it should be
white to move right the only way i see
this is knight d5 castle knight c3 back
but that didn't happen that makes no
sense
am i
am i the only one that what
somehow antipov stole two tempes that's
pretty good you should treat you should
teach me this trick
i don't know how he did miss you trick
right i don't know how he did what is
this he stole two templates when we
weren't watching what
how did he do it how did he do it
ah okay okay okay i know i know i know i
know
he made castle here bishop to h4 knight
to d7 bishop to g3 back
no way yeah why would you play bishop h4
though
to target knight but also why would you
bring the knight the bishop back
that is
uh because knight d5 just looks like a
much better option
i'm not confused we need to we need to
actually get the shot with the camera
because we don't have the position yeah
our our leach has not updated yeah yeah
unfortunately um we will stick with this
one
until the game's update
especially because we're also entering
the last five minutes yeah yeah and
because we're extremely confused about
how we got here
i'm not going to complain as uh as a
coach of uh michonne i'm not going to
complain look
you found a magic trick game two tempes
take it
take it and run away with it
well we'll uh i guess we'll have to find
out later somehow even with two temples
down it does feel like that knight d5 is
just coming i mean the thing is
coming and anything you stick on c5 i'll
go d4 happily expelling yeah oh why am i
i still i saw him black's position not
in love with his position
hate is a strong word but uh yeah
definitely not in love with his position
i was thinking bishop to e6 maybe try
again i really want to not allow you to
go 95 that's
but bishop e6 is going to be met by
bishop to f3 yeah bishop f3 is a big
issue because actually defending uh b7
is uncomfortable it also prepares 95
again you don't want to lose the pair of
bishops as black and i could always
consider going d4 that's not a great
position and d4 at that point actually
threatens to trap your bishop right i
couldn't even start with the move d4
threat of the trapper bishop ask you if
you really want to play bishop b3 where
the bishop is nicely anchored
but let's be real yeah it's very offside
yeah
no um and the time difference is huge at
the moment that's that's a big problem
for misha right now three minutes and 45
seconds and counting
six minutes and 30 seconds for vasquez
with the white pieces and definitely the
superior position
we should be using sex played after a
long thing
yesterday like to say same move faster
it's just better yeah now d4 is an issue
d4 is a real issue here d4 immediately
it doesn't really matter which move
order i think
i like this move bishop to f3 i like
it's a practical decision it's a lot of
cager yes
keep your options open
knight to c5
yeah but here uh d4 knight b3
d4 knight b3 yes rook c2 still feels
like black
he's hanging on more than at least i
have some active pieces right uh that's
the only thing he can hope for at this
at this point yeah that's true let's go
you have to take your chances right and
what are black's chances here because
they're not very much uh you got to have
some activity the pattern a4 is somehow
queening in certain variations you might
as well be a pawn
yeah that's the biggest option
and chance that you have right now but i
think i think vasquez should just say i
don't believe you
d4 knight b3 rook c2 he could yeah and
ask questions right
very pertinent questions there yeah
so it actually it actually was very
similar he played bishop e5 97 bishop g3
okay that makes sense yeah and then on
depop didn't repeat which is the crazy
part of me
why wouldn't you repeat there how do you
think you're better
what i don't know
by the way we're once again not using
the engine so yeah
so we have no idea but we we we do we
would expect white to be better d4 okay
d4 is on the board so d4
yeah and our board is back uh d4 knight
b3 looks forced to me
i don't see any other choice d4 knight
to b3 um do you have another move no
right where are you i think you
perhaps he's looking at bishop to be
three bucks b3 yeah queen d2 and where
do you put your knight
that's the thing
same move faster yeah you have to be
three you have to play knight b3 right
there's no choice
what am i missing here
that's one of the things about
misha he he sometimes finds some sort of
extremely weird way to play normal
positions
um
he always looks for some weird moves uh
that's that's one of his he has two
minutes left what is he
he needs to play knight to b3 come on
right
play knight to b3 either
like a minute
yeah exactly do it one minute faster
it's a 10 minute game a minute too late
you just have to play faster stressing
me out dude
knight to b3 rook to c2
yeah but roxy was such an obvious move
and i like that vodkas does that obvious
move played quickly
he's a much more practical player it
seems like yeah definitely so bishop b7
is still a threat that's that's a big
problem
d5 also is starting to look very
threatening yeah it's it is a bit of a
threat i still have five e4 star points
start pushing the pawns start maybe even
focusing on the king side
okay now
antipov needs to find a way to
coordinate his pieces and try to get
this a pawn
rolling down the board and he goes
knight a5
now with an obvious threat bishop to b3
is a threat so you have to defend
against that but d5 just seems like it
plays itself
and d5 is one of bishop bishop d5 also i
mean at this point i i think i had too
many options as white and
vasquez being a very practical player
just chooses one of them doesn't really
spend too much time perhaps look very
strong bishop d5 also looks very strong
let's have the bird's eye view until the
end of the game because right now it
does feel like antipov has uh one minute
and 35 seconds
and he just played this
ugly looking move c6
i really don't like this maybe he just
didn't see a choice but uh
giving the e5 square to the bishop c6
ftx e6 this is such a bad structure
for
black right now also take away yeah i
think e6 queen a1 honestly could just be
very practical and very simple right the
the spawn structure is just so
detrimental to black right now he's gone
queen g4 he said i want to mate you yeah
he's going for the e6 pawn queen to b3
played yeah
quickly at least this gives uh some
options i wasn't so sure about the move
queen g4 i think it's a move that's more
tempting than it is good yeah yeah no i
like this it gives a couple of temps
yeah
to the black side
because right now you have to defend
either with queen e4 which he did or
rook to c1 well queen e4 does have a
very big threat rook b1 is actually huge
traps the queen it well it doesn't trap
close to it but close enough right
and c6 is also being targeted as soon as
the queen is removed from it actually
queen e4 is a great move
queen e4
is a really nice move
knight to c4 is unfortunately for him
not possible he's playing e3
a3 rook to b1 and how do you plan on uh
what's the point
right b1 and and then what
queen c4 for example b takes c6 just
finishes the game right your bishop's
hanging i'm not sure so you take take a2
yeah but okay i can take with the knight
yeah you take with the knight and this
is just
well rook takes a2 here
ah but rook takes a turret takes e4 rook
a1 rook b1 here it's not checkmate yeah
that's funny okay let's go back to the
bird's eye view could be one queen to c4
is on the board
uh we expect bc and we think that's game
right bc does feel like it's finishing
things up unless
but
has some sort of miraculous i don't see
any miracles please
i don't see any miracles here i think bc
is strong and winning a bishop
bishop the thing is that works too that
probably works too right you just pick
up the a3 pawn or that exchange yeah no
that's um that's that's a good one
that's also good
i mean just because we didn't see it
doesn't mean it's not good it's just one
of many moves that win in this position
it's also a very practical it doesn't
give black or at least it doesn't feel
like it gives black any chances now
antipov under one minute
50 seconds and counting and let's not
forget it's two seconds delay
you're not actually gaining any seconds
yeah there's no increments so is one
pawn right now right but that was
d-pawn yeah that was the pawn that you
had in the position yeah that was your
that was your source of counter play
more than a pawn it was your source of
counter play and without it it seems
like black's position should fall apart
more than one way to skin this cat i
believe uh bishop on a3 is hanging you
could just move it i don't see a
secondary threat
he's playing the move knight e2
attacking this queen on c4 also a very
good move uh i don't know if you have
time to take on c4 oh sorry i'm not a c4
on b5
you might be forced to though but what
else what else right
yeah no um so queen takes b5 you can
play knight
knight d2 maybe
knight d2 is an option but 92 i just
take back
with the rook and you take on a3 i take
on c6 and then i take with the queen on
c6
i don't understand what if i just simply
take
i keep forgetting you're a pawn up
already so that's fine yeah i'm not
going to take on b6 but
i am a pawn off
and and 92 played it probably was the
fourth move
but
once again okay how many moves
i'm i'm pulling up at the end of
everything this whole thing also i can
just take on d2 you take on a3 and i go
look to c2 back
i don't even have to take on c6 first no
no you don't have to do any of these
things i think most of most of these
variations should be winning somehow
and the problem is
there is no counterplay for black this
structure completely kills
the dark square bishop
no i mean it's positionally and
materially winning here so it
and g3
yeah what what why not right kill the
bishop a little bit more give yourself
to loft don't blunder the game yeah i
like g3 it's a practical move it might
not even be a very good move according
to the engine i believe
but who cares and then you go knight f4
you go rook c2 first maybe knight f4
there yeah e6 is being targeted rook c2
is a humongous threat in this position i
don't know thank you for forcing me to
go roxy too directly to it just
finishing c2 finishes the game
you have to play c3 bishop to c3 yeah
but now i have options so many options
queen takes b7 is winning chris takes a6
queen takes c6 yeah this is uh just
simply yeah that's when they see six and
we see a queen trade
rook to d6
i mean somehow i get it it's winning but
this feels like the list winning no no
this is the most winning knight okay
knight to c7 might have been
good enough yeah you just take that take
on a3 nothing nothing there's no
problems here
you can just take on a3
it is an exchange
and only five seconds for antipov and
he's not gaining any extra seconds
if this one goes according to plan for
vasquez then
antipov will be in a must-win situation
with the white pieces going into the
second game of tie breaks takes a bishop
well if you take with the rook then rook
to b2 is coming and now i'm going to
target every single pawn
on the b file yeah this is this is the
cleanest way
let's move the king i think king to g2
you can also do that
yes and i think we will see a
resignation very soon is down two points
yeah it's a lot
yes don't go anywhere that is that is
the problem
yeah you start pushing
at some point you're going to have to
use your rook to gain my d pawn and i'm
going to gain your b pawn and that's
going to be four versus two yeah white
lads here right
yeah i'm not 100 sure why he played this
movie e4
everything is winning everything is
winning this is just a matter of
technique
yeah e5
squeezing
black
out and uh
f4
and that's it uh resize 1-0 for vasquez
remember it's a two-game match to make
it fair of course so misha will have the
chance to come back and bounce back with
the white pieces i think they play
immediately after
i do think so maybe they get like a five
minute
five minute break or anything of that
nature that's usually the case
and let's not forget this is actually a
very important uh match because
the winner gets sold first position in
terms of the trophy but
in terms of money as well oh yeah yeah
they are not sharing absolutely anything
winner takes all the money so
it is confirmed we will be having a five
minute break
and uh this is uh from our
humble calculations a fifteen hundred
dollar
match
very good
right now michonne tipoff with the white
pieces
is in a must-win situation now let's
analyze this game alejandro and let's
try to understand where everything went
wrong because
e5 came on the board confidently by
michonne tipo he was obviously prepared
he's been facing vasquez in the online
medium and they played this variation
before i don't know about e5 but they
played this particular position before
e5 before if i've
followed by d4 of course
that's an obvious idea to keep the
bishop away from
the home square on a b2 so now the
bishop is going to be redirected and i
really like this move a3
what do you think of this
alejandro
yeah you defend against bishop before
big move
knight to c6
bishop to g3
knight to f6
knight to f3
and it does seem like d takes c3 might
have been a big inaccuracy now at the
same time if we go even
if they didn't like knives did it f6
supposedly g5 was the right move yeah
okay that's not how we play chess right
but it does make some sense yeah once
you analyze it it kind of makes sense
right g5 you want to make this bishop on
g3 particularly uncomfortable now do you
know why it makes
sense for me because bishop g7 against
because i play the counts gambit do you
know the comments gamut i'm going to
quiz you it's not a thing that that is
definitely a thing
stop trying to make fetch a thing i'm
i'm going to show you the comments
gambit all right are you ready bishop to
g5 knight to e4 bishop to f
e5
d6
g5
so this is the khan's gambit why are you
subjecting me to the
it's it's a beautiful gambit i uh
welcome you to try it at any time it's
been thoroughly analyzed it's great for
uh for black is it our audience can can
definitely enjoy playing this one
and uh yeah also if you take check this
out
d5
and now you would probably take on d6
right that's forced right because it's
ambassador no it's not
because now i go queen f6 wow and you
resign wow
i'm teaching you the comments gave me
that
amazing alpha how did i even get to gm
without knowing this
it's a miracle it's okay it's okay but
of course b3 and um
all these sacrifices unfortunately were
in vain because to be honest after
knight c385
this position just crumbled yeah it's uh
it felt that
black didn't just not have compensation
for the pawn but because of the central
pressure white actually had the easier
play as well yes yes and that's once he
got a pawn back actually his position
was just terrible very crafty by vasquez
giving the pawn back
but retaining a clear
edge
from a practical point of view
also he was playing much faster than
antiboth yeah i mean the practicality of
his moves was just uh on another level
compared to supporting anything all
right well uh i assume it was smooth
sailing we are close we're we're getting
close to the start of the second right
game michonne tipoff once again in a
must-win situation
to force an armageddon yep
and um
let's see what he will choose
he was in a mastering situation to the
morning right in the classical time
control he is in a mastering situation
once again
against vasquez and now we see this he
takes d5
one of the preferred opening choice
of
misha antipov
c3
and he really enjoys playing this type
of positions now we see this kgc3
followed by h3
followed by e5 black is trying to
find the right approach and open up the
position as soon as possible
i never really liked uh
this car cons
for block
i always had a version of playing this
move b6
whoa wait what my goodness oh my
goodness that is made on in two if i
take on a6 but uh
excuse me yeah that's up to a6 ship a6
high
what a move
castle castle what a game we have on our
heads guys a must-draw game castle long
all right
straight into the fire what is going on
here
i do not believe in this for black at
all at all look he's playing fast and
he's signaling that he actually knows
what he's doing that might be a false
signal but
he's still mistakes confidently take
takes the rook so what if i go
no he takes wait what's happening
he just sacrificed the queen he played
it so quickly too
he was like yeah you know they said at
the studio that i'm playing slowly
whatever
second queen what is happening
what is this theory this might be some
sort of uh obscure theory it must be
i've never seen it definitely not aware
of
queen to c7 they they're both playing so
fast what's happening here i mean
vazquez plays fast but
for antipov to play fast i assume it's
theory
he'll castle and then go but there's a
ton a ton of compensation in this
position there is some compensation yes
yes yes um especially because it's very
difficult to find a square for the dark
square bishop for black bishop d6 is met
by 1995 almost always
and i will set up that pin bishop very
soon bishop f4 yeah
bishop c5 played
but once again they're both playing
extremely extremely fast i like to move
bishop c5 quite a bit actually because i
guess bishop f4 i can take on d4 take on
d4 and knight f3
simplifying the position simplifying the
position remember i am up a queen yeah
and all you need is a draw you have draw
odds
as black
yeah no i mean
it it started off um
theory this game and right now is slowly
slowly
easing into a very complex queen less
for white middle game
queen
i like that
so what's going on in this position uh
black has no real threats but r8 is
coming and black just wants to finish
development right yeah
why does a ton of compensation for the
queen rook maybe uh and a minor piece
but it's also the light squares around
the light the black king
and this is the determining factor
giving white some initiative
all right so let's go
what do we play here as white that's a
very good question bishop on c1 needs a
good square
and as you were mentioning this
unfortunately it does feel like it's
going to be met by knight to f3 forcing
the exchange and that's just too many
exchanges yeah that's too many exchanges
right i run out of uh mating material
maybe you're not worse with white but
you're definitely not better i remember
that it's just a must-win game uh
absolutely for antipov it doesn't have a
choice
yeah what a wild start to this game
right now it does feel like vasquez has
found a way
to stabilize the position sort of maybe
you have to go b4
b4 huh why not take sex queen c3 is not
dangerous because i have bishop p3 at
the end
so
maybe
bishop to e3 followed by rook to c1 or
c1 maybe knight b5 something like that
you will indeed have some problems on
that uh diagonal on that file yeah and
the diagonal the diagonals
yeah there's certainly a lot of
compensation here now before you
probably have to take them before but
then after bishop i think
if
f4 no bishop f4 yeah bishop to f4
so now taking advantage of the fact that
the knight on e2 cannot be relocated and
forced on d4 right
knight is always going to defend this
bishop no more knight f3 no more knight
f3 and now rook c1 is coming and i'm
gonna but then i
that's the problem now that you don't
have the b-pawn to hook my bishop and
what is the anti-puff thing he's
thinking that's what he keeps doing
that's what i keep not liking to e3
seven minutes compared to eight minutes
and 40 seconds
does he have enough initiative
well
yeah that's right enough first of all
knight to b5 perhaps it seems like quite
a quite a decent threat in this position
and if knight if not knight to uh b5
also
there's this
idea of playing a5
a5 is an idea before also uh you know
rears its head at some point yeah uh
removing the bishop on c5 by forces play
the move knight d5 i was actually
considering this but i couldn't
i couldn't make this one fully work uh
for black after what move knight b5
knight to b5
and i would assume you were looking at
ideas like yeah take stakes you have to
take on oh you could take it there
actually rook c1 but
once again it doesn't seem like you're
getting out no you could take on f1
though instead of taking on c2
take on f1 yeah and the knight actually
gets out through d2
but in the worst case for white i take
the pawn on a7 but um it's not so clear
that this is not clear no i mean
opposite color bishops i'm pretty active
it's definitely not clear but i don't
think he won this i want to be so i want
to be so unhappy with black some
simplification some clarification
uh 93 knight uh takes c7 looks forced
right yes yeah f5 is covered so there's
some intermediate check yes knight f1
also kind of looks forced
again i don't think he's going for this
i i don't think he wants this at all
you mean vasquez
vasquez yeah no i think he wants more
than this
i think he wants to keep more control
but what do you play though knight b5
queen summer where where
let's say e7
e7 is the only move right
that's a good point yes so let's just
show the audience why if you do go to d7
now unfortunately you have to face the
music after bishop today yeah bishop uh
pins the queen and on queen takes knight
d6 picks it up yes
that's a problem
so queen esa might be forced but let me
see if i can exploit that somehow
uh bishop takes c5 you're gonna take
with what
i really don't want to give you any
material back
so i'm going to take with the pawn
spooky but all right
yeah i mean i don't see any direct
threats for white so how the king on b8
hides pretty well it does it actually
does hide pretty well it does yeah yeah
yeah no um
i don't see
i don't quite see it either i really
don't see it and uh if you give me a
couple more moves i will go rook to d8
then the knight drops either to c7
potentially c7 also
no i i don't see enough compensation
for modern equality for white maybe
equality perhaps you have enough for
that but more than that in a must-win
game i don't see it you need to keep
those dynamic chances alive right i
don't quite see the problem is that i
really really really don't want to lose
this bishop on e3 for a night it feels
that this bishop is the last if you lose
that the game is over yes the match is
over the game is not over but the match
will be over
yeah that's how well well put because
remember white must win yes yes
absolutely must win you might make a
draw here and there you might have
enough compensation for that
four minutes left for misha i mean he
started off um
amazing yeah blazing fast but
has slowed the down since he gave up
that queen maybe it wasn't necessary to
give up the queen at that point
um no i don't know i it felt like an
interesting sacrifice when he did it it
did look a lot more dangerous he did it
so fast he did it so quickly so i'm
assuming it's some kind of theory
because look at how he thinks yeah he
he's one of those players that he
doesn't really know what he's doing he
spends so much time over the board such
a hard worker but right now you do need
some practicality to go with your hard
work you also need to have that time to
finish your opponent off when it comes
down to it absolutely and let's uh maybe
take a look at the bird's eye view just
to see
how much time we have left three minutes
and 30 seconds and he decides to give
the dark square bishop on e3 with the
move rook a to c1 knight takes e3
immediately comes on the board
takes c3 and
just hanging on by a thread right now
i don't like this it's it's it cannot be
enough
some precise technical moves by vasquez
i have a feeling we will
yeah you have to be a little bit careful
still is black okay for now b4 i assume
it's a threat b4 does seem to be quite a
significant trend yeah b4 is a pretty
serious threat so you need to stop it
somehow so why not king to b8
uh
king b8 looks like a logical move
yeah maybe king b8 i was a little bit
concerned about bishop e4
but you still have this knight on e5
which is great it's very important and
it's very hard to dislodge it no it's
almost impossible at some point you will
have to go for a
an exchange sacrifice with rook to f5
right
yeah but uh yeah
just hope it works right
and that's the thing about the position
it feels like hope chess a little bit
right now yep
hope trust an a5 plate i actually was
considering this move i didn't like weak
whoa
here we go i like that move
what i mean you were lost anyway if you
don't do anything so just let's go let's
mess it up might as well might as well i
mean a6 might be an idea it takes b6 as
an idea bishop e4 is now an idea yeah
yeah you have to go for it once again it
does feel like vasquez is just a few
moves away a few practical decisions
away but but here's the thing right it
was this particular move order you you
pop
you make your opponent pause you have
some threats some real real threats here
in this position let him handle it like
what king b8
king
i think a6
ace yeah a6 with the idea of knight b5
a7 at some point knight to b5 bishop b4
is the configuration that wins it's wins
it it's not even easy to stop it
right right so it's very hard to stop it
when he goes for a king b8 we might be
going straight into the game and i think
you have to play a6 because if you take
on b6 queen takes b6 is super safe it's
just super safe right there's nothing
what he took on b6 what i just i just
rambled i'm gonna cheat yes a6 was a
much better alternative
still losing so i have a feeling that
was
eight takes b6 practically much stronger
i guess he wants to go bishop before
rook a1
let's wait and see what vasquez is going
to decide to take back with
both options are possible bishop takes
b6 and queen takes b6
queen takes b6 bishop b4
yeah this is what we expected right but
rook a1
it's a threat it's not such a big deal
um i couldn't even play rook d8 here
you can indeed and start thinking about
sacrificing twice on d4 on d4 yeah no
absolutely that's uh that's an option
and i think he's going for it rook d.a
the practicality right guillermo is an
extremely practical player and he's
shown it
in this event
i
actually don't think that after rook to
a1 you can
you can do much after bishop takes d4 no
not much uh knight x4 rook takes d4
that's actually winning because you pick
up the bishop you do have a check on a8
but that doesn't do anything it doesn't
do anything and the c file is easily
covered by rook c4 anyway yeah rook v8 a
nice move by vasquez i really like
creating a threat and and this is
something that he does
quite well he maintains the initiative
all the time oh yeah with every single
move he never lets go of the initiative
if you give it to him do you do
it i would do it
i think i would do it take on d4 twice
yeah
i would do it actually three times yeah
three times you take three times on d4
the knight is strong you're not gonna
get made it i mean these two rooks and
the bishop they're strong but they're
not gonna made you it is a practical
decision that you could be thinking
about and this is exactly why he's
pausing yeah
i think it's smart
to uh
reduce the amount of things you can
blunder right precisely and
things that you can blunder for example
include things such as if you go b3 and
trying to put the pawn on b2 knight
takes b3 yeah some stuff like that
remove the knight from e5 you'll blunder
something you never know from e5
knight c6 might be a threat at some
point so he's just getting rid of all of
those things he's going for it and he's
going to take yeah yeah this is i think
this is this is what we thought was good
practical play
no doubt he's going for this
and
i think
white is not losing
but you aren't winning yeah you're not
winning this in in a million years uh
the problem is you don't have a stable
outpost for the bishop yeah you don't
have also a mechanism to get rid of the
b pawn the b-bone actually just stays on
the board
i think it stays on the board on b2
which is the most ugly thing
and uh we see that
that spot being twirled
yeah i'm not sure what you would call
that
perhaps d4 maybe
depending on how you look at it what
angle you look at that's funny
yeah
all right and it does seem like at this
point antipov is just uh
unfortunately
yeah coming in succumb coming to
realization right on this one i mean the
thing is
b3 b2 might be uh serious no that's what
i was saying yeah yeah right the pawn
gets to be two by fours there's nothing
you can do to avoid it followed by
knight to c4 reinforce that pawn on b2
like it wouldn't surprise me that the
position is just one completely lost
yeah for white yeah that that could be
the case could very well be the case
but once again
we come back to the practicality of it
antipov has been playing very slow you
cannot allow yourself to come down to
your last one minute come on go look at
four go rook at four and hope that he
blocked herself
but even that doesn't make anybody a
threat right yeah rexella's right
on c8 and even that then gave my beard
to f5 d7 yeah yeah so even that probably
is a drawback actually i think it is
yeah yeah and maybe not even that hard
yeah
midnight already e5 controlling
everything yeah it's pretty hopeless but
i you have to try
he's going for this bishop to f5 hinting
at the fact that one of the rooks will
get involved that will give a check
that's on c8 and that's going to be the
end yeah this is a good time i think to
go
i mean even actually g6 is a good move
yeah
once again focus on uh the lack of
squares for the bishop yeah that's like
that's a really good time to go g6 yeah
why does it why not no g6 d1 well we
missed that
played quickly by
antipath definitely saying that hey
hey i saw this i saw this move g6 i saw
that was a terrible time to be played
perhaps not the best time yeah actually
bishop if i was quite clever
the king is
going to go for a walk now the question
is how long of a walk
and we will get an answer in just a few
minutes
one queen to f4 seems like the right
move going to f4 that's my that would be
my
guess and my spot
i i just don't want to allow you to get
back with the bishop to e4 no i agree
with that actually the the bishop
getting to
point
the same idea
yeah but it doesn't keep a tab on the c1
rook which i actually like from oh it's
the d8 square that's true
so perhaps this is what he uh what he
wanted to achieve rook to d5 by
b5 is a threat wait a minute wait a
second
that's what i like queen f4 because
you keep an eye on the rook on c1
i really like queen f4 a lot better your
move i like that e5 and guillermo right
now
fall is back in his chair
what's going on rook b5 followed by rook
to a1 we have a game it's a check mating
threat also your knight on e5 will drop
this
what a miss
king to b7 but now bishop to c8 followed
by rook takes e5
it takes e5
wins right it
seems like it does wow queen h4 was a
blunder wow rook d5
wow
he's back into this match out of the
blue
we thought that he's completely lost
bishop d7 yeah bishop d7 rook to b4 no
but bishop b7 two and that would be
right b one
ah yeah yeah just don't get fancy that
was clever
but he only has 40 seconds left on the
clock right yeah that's the main issue
with the people's position is his clock
he just needs to get rid of the b-pawn
and he'll be in a winning position but
10 seconds left for him 30 seconds
30 seconds why 30 seconds left rook to
b1 okay
targeting the pawn on b3 now
how are you going to stop
yeah the point is queen e4 you have rook
a6
which is kind of important but you do
have it oh point to e root 2 a6 is a big
move right there
and in fact how do you defend how do you
defend this pawn right yeah how do you
defend the pawn queen to e3 but i mean
three three just feels like you're
giving me an extra tempo the queen e3 is
nice because it does control b6 but now
i can give you a chat where ah
it's a good move i like that move
consolidating
and perhaps at times
later on bishop
to be one to d1 will be a threat as well
rook takes b3 is a big threat yeah rook
b3 is a finishing finishing the game
type of threat and in fact i don't oh oh
rook b3 right three just finished the
game
actually how is that endgame the
question is what
okay king king had to go to c4
now this is just lost i mean yeah what
do you mean the three versus two it's
completely winning you're up a piece yes
but it's the wrong part but who cares
right
okay now
yes this this ma wow what a game
what a game
g5 but rook fire rookie f5 i think it is
takes five as a threat oh
wow misha and tipoff from the dead
fights back fights back forces in
armageddon because this is it rook b7 is
game he was like the undertaker in this
game he was like the undertaker in this
game i'm telling you he came back from
the death is he trying to get stalemated
he just gave all his points
with his last three moves not that he
had a huge alternative yeah yeah but
black is just getting mated here the
rooks are going to
the rook's with the bishop
no
we're going to see an argument on
alejandro that's incredible
that is incredible unless
it's over
you got made a rook c6
that works too
it's also an option
bishop to e4 now rook to b2 is a thread
direct b1 and rook a2 is made yes wow
misha deep of with the tricks let's go
back to that position actually
and uh by the way somebody was in and
chad mentioned if queen takes b it was
missed it was not because rook takes b3
check was actually a skewer when misha
played rugby 8 and then took on b3
yes yeah it was actually not a mistake
yeah i mean queen f4 was the right move
when far was the right move right
we're actually looking at um
the engine right now and queen to f4
seems to have given black a slight
advantage uh we don't know who's going
to get
what color
antipov will actually choose
uh he chose right now and i would assume
white would be his choice i don't know
anybody that chooses black do you know
anybody that actually chooses black five
versus four um yeah
especially with no increment
after 60 moves you have to choose one
you have to choose fight
so for all the marbles and for fifteen
hundred dollars extra first place price
we have an armageddon game in our match
wow
what a finish to this tournament yeah
this is pretty great actually what a
finish to this tournament and uh
it was just all about the nerves i have
to say um vasquez just wasn't able to
contain his nurse in that last
game queen to f4 was
an easy move to make
and i think tighter control a little
tighter
yeah somehow g6 was actually uh a little
too loose i feel and what i think he got
tempted by um
was the control over the d8 square at
that point yeah i think so too so as we
go yes rfd1
yeah he just like the fact that he's not
getting checked on d8
if you go rook to ca then this after
king to b7 just loses there's no squares
for the bishop i'm going to pick it up
but
and this is by the way an easy move to
miss
rook to d5
right which was spotted immediately and
actually it just gives white a
tremendous advantage
what
a change yeah what a change
in in pace from uh
from what we've seen in game one in this
game too
but look you have to applaud
the fighting spirit of
michonne
he went for it right he went with all
this whole craziness with b4 and stuff
he knew that he's losing he knew that he
had to know that he's losing yeah
you just kind of went for it
so apparently it is all theory this
entire sacrifice sacrifices
but there are no games
and i think they're getting ready to
start
both players extremely extremely poised
and uh and ready to make a splash and
take home the victory in the
championship
and the mullah
and the money of course
this is a 1500
armageddon game that's a pretty big game
yeah for collegiate play for collegiate
players this is a significant bonus
um
and right now as you see michonne tipoff
representing the university of missouri
and vasquez representing university of
texas at dallas that's right i think
they're actually uh the first sports for
both teams right
no
alparine is definitely you still have a
part
well we're working on that maybe
all right let's go we got our armor
getting game bishop team against
guillermo vazquez
off to the races as we have a solid
italian remember on in case of a black
victory guillermo takes the tournament
in case of a drug yerma also takes the
tournament so misha is absolutely forced
to win yet again with the white pizzas
he won against jj he won against vasquez
in the tiebreak to force this armageddon
let's see what we do we actually have a
very interestingly the same position
that we had earlier today uh between
abhimanyu mishra
and nicolas theodoru which ended in a
very very easy and solid draw there for
the greek player
no absolutely and right now
antipath
needs to take advantage of his extra
minute and put some immediate pressure
on his opponent still 50 seconds ahead
on the clock right now bishop to e3
we're going to see probably knight takes
e3 and
how do you feel about the strategy to
play a long game like this because we
know this is going to be a long game you
do have the extra time and most likely a
more pleasant position right b5 and this
has all been uh very similar to what we
had earlier today
i'm not yeah you play like this rook a1
b5 t take rook a1 i think is what theory
says
i mean this is some kind of really
really long variation which i'm not
really sure why people are so happy to
go into was black
but they seem to be and it seems to be
actually more equal than i gave it
credit for absolutely and oh well i mean
he's catching up on time so this is
typical right this is so typical for uh
antipov he needs to use the time
advantage come on that is a big right
now for vasquez catching up on time and
position i have to say is starting to
look more and more equal from my
perspective you can you can even take
and go rook d6 i don't see anything
wrong against it knight to e7 that is a
logical very logical move opening up the
sixth rank potentially
rook to c6 will come potentially knight
to g6 followed by knight to f4 later in
the game
and reinforcing the control over d5
yeah
not so easy to find a move here for a
while do you want maybe just for k1 play
something quickly oh king h2
also a useful move
uh gets out of the checks on the first
rank also you never know when that's
useful
but you have to play faster right faster
i think it still has a solid 20 second
advantage well a little less than that
yeah time is basically
so no no advantage in time anymore i
mean vasquez just
feels like the better blitz player but
right now after c6 the knight is coming
to c5 that's fine
rook to d6 knight to b3 yeah knight b3
but i have to play it fast knight b3 i
expect knight g6 i think but knight g6
is going to be met by knight to f5 and
you might
is going to get bounced around
yeah an issue
not only that but knight c5 actually
it's we have an exchange
so queen on c8
just pre uh for seeing that this knight
is going to be on c5 so you want to move
the queen from the square you don't want
this knight to hop with a tempo
you want avoiding any sort of exchanges
but you take on e4 take on e4 and i
don't really know why you gave me the d5
less
that's an extra tempo and you can cover
up the c5 square with knight d7 which he
did
c4 came on the board c4 creating another
weakness in black's position the pawn on
c6
i like it i like c4 actually knight f8
seems a bit passive and now now white
space advantage might be telling i'd
have faded to c1 i like rook c1 oh i
don't know
oh that doesn't feel like the right move
i don't yeah why why are you closing
down the queen side right c5 i see five
why not rook ec one i thought that was
the entire point no that that was a very
very uh suspicious move
c5
all right so what is this idea he wants
to target
i just don't get it because c5 seats the
only open file in the position to his
opponent right the only open file right
now is the d file and with move c5
you've basically secured
the c file for black because you don't
have rookie c1 you don't have a way to
create any counter play down on the
queen side now
it feels and he's down on time now yeah
yeah
two minutes and 15 seconds two minutes
and 27 seconds and counting for vasquez
and he's taking over the initiative i i
think so too i just like black's
position better now rook d3 coming on
the board you can even think of the
other row coming to d4 he is taking over
that move c5 was such a bad thing
what if knight d4 here
knight d4 is the move but
knight d4 right take on d4 with the
knight no but then paul takes and it's
check oh that's a check yeah pawn takes
his check i think knight d4 was winning
just winning
a big miss yeah knight d4 was not
immediately winning but because he had
miraculous miracle queen a2 rook a7 that
nobody would have looked at yeah
and right now misha is coming back yeah
because knight d4 i mean he didn't
actually penetrate he played root e3 and
all the way back he doesn't feel like
vasquez has a plan he's going back to d3
rookie i guess
it is a move now followed by knight to
a5 later on in the end game puts a lot
of pressure this is the idea right
and knight to f5 this is what he's
looking for queen to c to rook to d7
offering a potential um i mean
of course he's
i don't like putting the knight on a5
first i mean it's easy to do the
commentary when you're not playing the
armageddon but
but so disgusting still everything to
play for right now
one minute 26 seconds against one minute
and 50 seconds that's a big such a time
difference time advantage for vasquez
right now oh shocked they didn't take on
b3 and guru d3
finally
finally we have this k8
but he has to play faster antipov has to
play faster because
let's not forget this game will finish
without absolutely any increment in one
minute and 20 seconds for mishand typo
in one minute and 30 seconds for vasquez
a little bit of hesitation here doesn't
want to go king h7 wants to go rogue d8
but
queen 27 speeding up yeah but it's clear
that this queen on c7 is the big problem
right but taking allows the rook to
enter the position now knight a5 is
definitely the 95 on the board you start
hitting the spawn on c6 you start
really thinking about it pressure right
now right there is some pressure now
can i take on e7 i'm sorry what why
might think on e7 yes you could have
taken on a7
on e7 followed by knight to c6 that was
a missed opportunity but but this also
looks strong because knight f5 is a
threat roof takes f7 sorry how are we
doing on time right now my goodness no
but now antipov is completely winning
he's actually penetrated he got the f7
partner this knight is coming to f5 and
he has more time and he has more time
like everything changed in the last
couple of moves knight f5 looks like a
winning round 25 is a winning rook end
game
yes
with conviction played 97 is the third
next xd4 is the threat you cannot take
on f5 and hope to survive that no but
you have to what else do you have right
there's nothing there's nothing c2 is
followed by knight to e7 yeah that's a
problem this end game is completely
busted
40 seconds 43 seconds against 56 seconds
this is going to go down to the wire
but king goes to e4 but it is over it's
a big time advantage and it's so much
easier to play for white right king
after king four you don't have to think
take the pawn rook to a4
looking to gain that's
some material back rook to c4 it's an
option basically c6 pushing baby
c6 feels c6 winning technical exactly c6
push and trade these pawns but you still
have to make the moves that doesn't yeah
right b7 put the pawn on c7
you can even go f4 i wasn't very happy
with that one but okay
this is good enough check on c3 was met
with king h4 no problems 25 seconds and
now rookie rugby five so that you can go
g5 actually this works also so i like
this one it takes b3 is a threat
take that pawn go rook to b6
get the king to g5
or the point yeah i think you get the
pawn to g5 or f6 f6
but f6 is g6 right g6 yes yes yes this
is not over
and remember he's playing so slowly he's
playing
he's down on time now
oh this is going to go down to the one
he has to play faster
oh
[Music]
ah but this is pretty hopeless yeah
i don't know 11 seconds he he will try
that's
three wins
win games and they took them all he won
every single one of them you were
mentioning that antipov had not won a
single white game
in the entirety of his uh group a in the
spring classic and in the entirety
of the b group in this tournament until
today yes where he won not one not two
but three on-demand games with white
pieces wow that's excellent
he takes an extra fifteen hundred
dollars as well as the title
of 2022 summer chess classic champion
what a comeback what a comeback or the
young player
wow misha antipov there with his cool 4
000
first place prize certainly showing
why he was a member of the age group in
the previous tournament saying look
you're going to relegate me to the beer
group no problem i'll win that one and
get myself invited yet again and he took
that personally
very personally right
yes absolutely and with this victory
most likely he will uh get an invitation
in the uh fall
classic in the a group but we will
confirm that
later
here at the st louis chess club we don't
want to give any
contracts around
from the commentator seat but um yeah
while we wait for michonne tipoff to
come down for an in alejandro
your thoughts about this event no it was
great i really like doing this
commentary i really always like the
classic series it's one of the most
important in my opinion little
niche tournaments that we have here at
the club tournaments that are easy to
replicate in other parts of the world
not so many 2600s available down the
street and but it's such an excellent uh
trading ground for our players for the
collegiate players around here for
mishra bimanu i mean like what what a
great tournament this is for him to
practice and get better and it's always
exciting you see all these fights
between players that perhaps you don't
have on your radar as their top players
to follow but certainly strong grand
masters that are really trying their
best and showing why they are
very close to the elite oh absolutely
and what a finish uh this one and
perhaps we will be able to see the
standings right now as we are waiting
for uh mihail antipov to come down but
what a finish this was and uh michonne
tipoff he started off slow
he started off extremely slow and by the
way check this out today in chess
candidates edition i have to say uh i'm
not 100 sure if our screen is wrong
right now but uh that's a little bit
suspicious uh nevertheless pixelated
edition pixelated edition
8-bit
edition june 17th through july 5th uh
that's a week from now that's going to
come up very shortly uh that's going to
be a very fun and exciting and
influential
tournament probably the most influential
tournament for the past year and a half
since uh well actually for the past year
since last november since the world
championship
match uh the candidates tournament is
going to be a battle of attrition
between eight players voting
for
the title as well
as the spot of challenger for the next
world championship
match and we are actually ready right
now we have in the studio the winner of
the big group here at the summer chess
classic
young mikhail antipov mihail
congratulations
big victory for you you came into
today's round trailing half a point uh
compared to jj alimorandi you are in a
must-win situation how did you approach
that game
i just decided to play
bishop b5 on the third move instead of
usual bishop c4
and
i mean i didn't try to make some really
big risk out of the opening just to win
so i mean i just decided to play i think
i got like almost completely equal end
game
but i mean he did like maybe one in
accuracy and suddenly when i played
knight g4 and he he took on g4
so it was already quite complicated for
him i i really want to pull up that game
because
the finish was just incredible for us
that one definitely a crazy game now
we're not going to go through all the
nuances of the game but i should want to
look at this position
i was thinking that my position was just
completely completely winning right but
it wasn't that easy to find the final
blow yes like i played g3 on move
forward probably 97 was me was swinging
immediately instead of g3
g3 knight to a7 yeah but it was move
forward
uh he played knight 496 is a way like i
just didn't calculate at all so what may
be very some trick so g3 i mean i'm not
wondering anything for sure and i will
just think after that but sunday g3 is
quite a big inaccuracy yes because of
the bishop g5 now everything is not so
simple and by the way this is still i
mean you still have to calculate a
little bit yeah nevertheless it doesn't
look like this one is that's what i say
after bishop d5 just winning yeah
um and
you did feel like you missed that
particular moment yes i still felt like
you're winning right no this moment for
the time completely win i was just
shocked by his move knight
b6 i completely missed that because i've
calculated on the rook c6 and i thought
what i'm just winning after but somehow
i don't think i really don't remember
what i wanted to do yes here but i mean
this place should be just completely
maybe 1996 i think was one of the most
easiest way sorry 96 i can just go into
this yeah just maintain a decent
pressure and
my vision is definitely completely wean
so
in case even if i made something
accuracy it can still it's still uh
let's say an easier technical task yeah
but after knight b6 only things are not
simple at all because i i completely
missed that it's possible to let me play
with bishop g8 and suddenly i have no
simple way to continue so as i
understand i messed it up whenever you
spend a lot of time right now yeah i'm
to be honest i miss evaluated to five
because i thought after five my position
should be all three and this was the
move that we were discussing here in the
studio as well it just felt like the one
that gives black the most chances yes i
missed i missed that now after for
example rook d6 yes knight a4 yes i just
completely escaped my mind but after you
d7 can get eight knight d6 i'm not
getting to play knight f7 because he
goes kill g7 and king f6 right and this
is
i mean there's no checkmate because yes
wow
so to be honest i also expected h5 from
him i just
just didn't see what f5 is working and
he played h5 and after this it just felt
like first of all
when did you see this uh
g5 tactic
did you see it all the way from afar yes
yes when i played rugby
all the way from b8 wow
i was considering rook g6 and rook b8
but i thought that after ub6 maybe he
can try to play king of fights at some
moment excuse me it's it was more was
the same but
knight a4 d7
k6
and knight g6
bishop c1 knight f7 yes king g7 knight
five but maybe he'll make it yes maybe
kim gray so at least i'm not making him
so that's why i decided to play hook
beat because this mario kart on b7 i
just go knight g6 yes yes yes
right
uh and you got this position after g
yeah i think he just missed this idea
because if i don't go for g5 and g4
at least it's not so simple for me
maybe i'm also winning somehow but
at least i didn't see any other simple
option to win still uh you finished this
game in style that must have given you a
boost of confidence but how are your
energy levels entering the tie brings
you knew that you still have a big match
to play
uh i was just completely tired of after
the game so i was
extremely worried about my shape because
like i had completely been in position i
even made it almost to a drone
so i was i was not really happy about
that but
i mean i had some time to relax and when
i came to fabric i felt more you felt
more or less fine and let's talk about
tie breaks as well because the tie
breaks well they didn't start in the
best way for you right they had three
extremely interesting games now you
started off with this movie e5 yeah if i
watched it a little bit it's quite a
funny way to react against this opening
because i immediately put some problems
to my opponent and i think my huge
mistake was when i played knight f6 i
just realized it after because instead
of knight f6 i could play g5 and bishop
g7 yes this was much better because now
c3 is not possible my positions
is probably just better because like
all his pistols stacked he doesn't have
a bishop to guard yes and not allow him
to open up the long diagonal yeah so i
played knight f6 immediately
having ideas to go 95 at some moment and
when i realized that it's just a huge
mistake already right knight to f3
because now knight to d5 is uh not
coming with as much poise
bishop to c5 and somehow it's already
very unpleasant yeah yeah
um i managed to get some chances but i
think that still was worse
right and and he did give you back the
a3 pawn quite handily and then okay
let's talk about the second game
the second game
you guys
blitzed out this variation
yes they were extremely confused because
we've never seen this before did you
guys actually play against each other
this did you analyze this no it's
actually quite funny i just analyzed it
long time ago and when i saw the
position after bishop c2 my first
thought if it's possible to play b6 and
bishop a6 and b6 was just played maybe
three times right but he played it
instantaneously yes yes and
i
i saw it after b6 my only memory is to
go knight e3 knight b5 and when i think
i noticed it like two years ago i don't
yes i remember how to continue i
remember but it just
impressed me that i can just sacrifice
my queen and play for initiative yes so
i think that bish putin was a decent
mistake for me because if you see it's
bishop e3 yeah and i just shot to c5
yeah probably i should go with bishop g5
this was probably a better option
it does seem like that is the computer's
choice as well bishop to g5 i need to
somehow develop my bishop to open c1 for
my rook but after bishop g5 i actually
actually can go with this page for
bishop g3 yeah and bishop four was not
working because he can take and go
knight of three yeah so somehow i
thought that i i need to like maintain
two bishops but you played bishop to e3
and after knight to d5 now it's already
starting to look quite
difficult for you to find the counter
chances and i just tried to like give
some
complications complications for him yeah
because it is not my position's
definitely not great yeah but at least
uh it's not so simple for him to
different because his team is always
weak after bishop before i mean i can i
have lots of ideas right and you started
off with uh b4 followed by a5 did you
consider a6 at all no i thought i should
just open him open him up not knight to
b5 potentially followed by a7
you took
the position is just completely over
just lost yes
and um
you play this move a bishop to f5 and g6
came on the ball rook fd1 you kind of
played it quite quickly now it felt like
you're seeing something
and yet he played this move queen to h
and that's where it's just tossed i
think after w5 at least it's extremely
scary right did you see it uh from afar
was this your i was surprised with
screen h4 because i thought that he goes
queen f4 queen f4 and the problem for me
that i cannot even move my bishop away
because he can play knight f3 and i mean
he's of cable because
bishop to b1 or anything of that nature
he can even do this yeah so i thought if
i just go look at fun and then i will
think i mean definitely my position is
not great but
maybe i would be able to put some
problems and after that queen to h4 was
just a tremendous blunder you definitely
um
one handily and you guys got into the
armageddon
quite interesting game you chose white
um
take us through this game you guys i
think the smallest it's smaller stereo
one is also ethereal
b1 yeah yeah b5 is a possible move i
think argent proposes like 97 something
like 97 after ub1
and uh but he played b5 yeah it's
possible now c5 is a bit weak so i just
tried to make accurate moves not too
long it felt like you're building up the
pressure and then this move came on
the board i'm trying to find the exact
moment when you play this move c5 which
we really didn't like yeah knight to f8
and right now you played this move c5 i
mean i had to do something and this is
absolutely it's a please yeah it's
not even a bluetooth server yet i'm
being a bit too picky about these moves
uh you have to do something of course of
course g5 is not the best move because
uh like right nothing is handing for him
d4 is just a weakness for his knight
yeah and uh like i put support because
like
in such games like armageddon you start
thinking about like in case like we just
play simple chess and we exchange
something like it's better like to have
your pawns like pushed forward
yeah
more advanced than your opponents uh
mihail this is a huge victory for you
after quite an unfortunate uh group a
event a couple of months ago you came
back with a vengeance in the big group
and won the big group
did you think at any point after the
first five rounds when you drew every
single game and every while vasquez and
jj alimorandi were running away it felt
like it with the event did you feel like
you have any chances to catch them
i thought i thought i had chances but
when
arbiter announced it with
jacobson just drove from a tournament
and
my main
opponents got like plus
an extra an extra point half a point
yeah i was there to europe i was
thinking that i i mean
have maybe some kind of theoretical
chance um
well mihael a big victory for you once
again congratulations
um
you have a lot of fans around the world
a lot of fans in your home country as
well as the united states any final
words for them
just want to say thank you to everyone
who
organized this event
it's a great pleasure to play in such
place
i mean despite the fact that i played
extremely badly in spring i still
enjoyed this tournament a lot because
there are
not that many tournaments with such
great conditions
mikhail congratulations and uh here we
have it folks the winner of the big
group here at the summer chess classic
grand master mikhail antipov and uh
we're going to have to take a look at
the standings and see where all the
players
have finished
we're going to do the countdown starting
with the b group in a 10th position
we have brandon jacobson who
unfortunately had to withdraw from the
tournament after round number five with
two and a half points he finishes off in
the last position tigran harut union who
unfortunately for him did not have a
great
result either three points out of nine
in ninth position nico checker with a
victory in the last round he finishes
off on three and a half points tied for
six position we have john burke and
zuzon ciao with four points a piece
in fifth position we have christopher eu
tied for third position jj alima randy
and camille dragoon and tied for first
is guillermo vasquez and misha antipov
and after the tie breaks it was
mihael antipov who finishes off
as the winner of the big group
and takes home a nice cool check four
thousand dollars alejandro not bad let's
take a look at the finish of the a group
where again we unfortunately had ray
robson not be able to finish the
tournament a very surprising finish in
ninth position for sam savion annually
meant the 2700 no longer 2700 after this
event uh elias mir and jonas beer and
aram hakobian finished as well as
benjamin gledura all finished in three
and a half points which is good enough
for tide for fifth uh nicolas theodoro
has a great event uh finishing on fifty
percent with four out of eight and abby
manu mishra shows again that he is an
excellent chess player not just a
talented youth four and a half points
for him a superb event gregory aparing
comes back and also finishes with four
and a half day tied for second place but
without a doubt head and shoulders above
of the competition juiyongi was the best
player in this tournament uh no
questions six thousand dollars goes to
him for a very clean performance
oh an amazing performance by yu yang he
is such an amazing player and lit level
player but we do have eight
top of the top level players uh playing
in the candidates which starts actually
in less than a week less than a week
christian is actually first round is
going to be on uh the 17th june 17th so
it's really really really around the
corner i know some of the players are
already in madrid uh finishing up their
training camps and we of course will be
uh broadcasting this live for you guys
so don't forget
it will be uh myself uh alejandro as
well as one yasser sarah one who is
joining us mr yasser mr yasser will be
back in st louis and we will be having
full coverage of the candidates starting
from day one all the way until the end
we're not doing an abbreviated coverage
we're starting from move one all the way
until they finish the games
perfect and we do have also a nice group
photo to finish this one it was a
pleasure alejandro absolutely a pleasure
and thank you everybody that's in this
picture for making this possible without
you guys obviously none of this happens
uh
i got a picture it's great it's great
stuff
well thank you all and thank you for
watching our show i hope you enjoyed our
summer classic and we'll have to follow
classic in november so if you're looking
for more of this chess we'll be having
it back
see you next time
[Music]
this has been a presentation of the st
louis chess club any reproduction or
distribution of this content without the
express written consent of the st louis
chess club is prohibited
you